Ladies and gentlemen, welcome to WrestleMania 24!
We have an outstanding evening prepared for you tonight.
I am your last minute replacement, ring it down sir,
Takahata.
I normally serve drinks, but tonight I'm going to be serving
up some announcing of some of the best wrestling that come
out of the wrestling sphere and the V-Tuber sphere, a
collision of Titans, and a complete combination of talents
in a collab that can only end in absolute anarchy.
And this is all being called by an amazing announced team,
and I'd like to cut to them right now if we can.
Hello, hello everybody!
Welcome to WrestleTuber 2024.
So I'll be here to introduce to you guys the format of this
event.
We apologize for the delays here.
There was been some last minute replacements, some last
minute sub-ins.
Unfortunately, Sayu is currently experiencing some delays
today, but he will be here tomorrow to continue the
announcement.
So huge shout out to Taka for subbing in.
Super last minute.
He's literally writing notes on how to announce, like, as we
speak.
We actually, we actually, like, five minutes before the
stream was supposed to start.
He was like, wait, so what am I supposed to announce when we
start the event?
And I was like, oh, shit, okay.
Let me see if I can figure out what you're supposed to say.
So huge shout out to Taka for coming in last minute.
to help us out he actually has i believe uh he is one of two
members uh in this event that has uh the most wwe experience
out of all of us so really came in clutch for us here anyway
welcome welcome to wrestle tuber um i am very nervous i'm
scared there might be a lot of scuff going in i am merely
one person controlling the entire obs right now so i do
apologize for the scuff in advance.
We're already behind schedule too.
So huge shout out to all the members, all the VTubers coming
in here, giving up their day and time to be participating in
this event.
They're really giving up their time to be here, to wrestle,
to give their interviews.
They'll all be here.
Everyone that's participating will be here in some shape and
form.
So really huge shout out to every participating member.
Anyway, we actually have the belt now if you guys would like
to see what the belt would look like so um the people who
are winning the show matches and the tournament there's
going to be a show matches and tournament for each day so
the show match will open up uh the people who are part of
the show match will only be there for one match and then
they'll be gone and then we'll go straight into the
tournament format uh and each winner of both the show
matches and the tournament will receive the WrestleTuber
belt!
Oh, that's me, I moved.
This is what the WrestleTuber belt is going to look like.
Gamersup is fully funding and sponsoring this event, and
they will be providing and shipping out the WrestleTuber
belts to the winning participants, to the champions.
Also, each participating member is gonna receive a little
gift as a thank you for participating in WrestleTuber so uh
so everybody the staff um the staff and the the wrestlers
themselves will each receive something uh just as a little
thank you to be like thank you for being here now the
brackets before we start um here is the bracket one uh we'll
have bracket one and bracket two most likely bracket three
might be on day two we're not sure.
It depends on how long this is going to take.
It depends on how fast the matches are or how slow the games
are going to be.
So here are the brackets.
We're going to have Lyme and Kai firsting up first and then
Emma and Rin.
And apparently the biggest, one of the biggest matches of
today.
Gerard and Assyria.
We're going to see if Gerard's going to survive another
extinction.
And then we have Fuyo and Snuffy.
So that would be your bracket.
one um bracket one for day one uh we might have we're we are
absolutely gonna have bracket two uh we're not sure about uh
bracket three yet because uh you know these take a while so
it's gonna be interesting how how long it is gonna be anyway
before we begin um we do have our first match of today
before we go straight into the turn of whoa wait whoa oh
wait you guys didn't hear that i told you guys there might
be scuffed along the way and i realized you guys didn't hear
what i just heard but but don't worry please play that
replay
That was backstage?
Wrong.
It equals fish.
It does not.
Filtered.
It definitely equals fish.
Are you?
Ah.
Are you sure about that, Centrea?
Maybe you flunked math.
Yes.
fish.
Man, Zintre is really brainwashed herself.
You don't even know what 4 plus 4 is, I bet.
Well, I don't mess around scent.
None of that adding to fish with me.
I have a quick question for you.
Please do.
Since you're trying to find my dad, what if I showed you my
dad?
That may work.
I can talk like you guys can, chat, chat, chat, chat, chat,
chat, chat.
Your text-to-speech is extremely confusing.
I wouldn't mind hearing real chat though.
Speak for yourself.
What the fuck?
How's that?
As long as I can still make sense Vidal.
This stream is first and foremost about making sense,
anything else is just an added bonus.
my god do you even know anything about wrestling i could
tear john cena apart
you can't even see john cena that's what he thinks centuria
so that begs to differ the point
exactly okay listen sorry i uh what were you saying so let's
say
intelligent isn't that right twitch chat okay it looks like
you found my dad by the way chaos underscore lives on 123
omega street is not a valid address i would like to
congratulate you on finding him i haven't found him yet but
i'm glad you're optimistic actually i don't know if that's
even my dad i'll let you decide that when i do find him i
kind of just found him out in the
that based on your last comment maybe you're mistaken
yeah i just found some homeless guy out in the forest and i
decided to call him big papa bear in a forest oh my god i
can't believe it that's what i'm looking for right off the
bat they're fighting backstage
yeah he doesn't really say much please ladies girls You're
supposed to take it in the ring!
What are you doing here?
He does, yeah.
Hey, chat.
I kind of look like Hulk Hogan.
We haven't, I don't even have my Hulk Haster here yet.
And they're ready to play, and they're ready to fight.
I hope I'm not the next thing you think about.
Ladies, please.
I probably should not have brought this guy from the forest.
I think returning them would be a great idea.
I was just less speechless.
I can't believe it.
Our show matches were supposed to be in the ring, but yet
these ladies just couldn't stop!
And how would you know...
There isn't even a ref!
Who is controlling?
How would we know the winner?
Because every time I talk to them, they would just grunt.
Perhaps they are just lacking intelligence.
There are remarkably few bilingual grizzlies.
Zen just... No, that's Zen.
Zen just happens to change into the bear elf.
I don't know about the intelligence part, but I do know that
they are super fucking strong.
Oh my god, who would win?
Beerman versus a little girl.
This shouldn't even be legal.
Oh my, the little girl has a fucking chair.
What is this all going to do?
Not the chair!
But I would appreciate it if I had you in the long.
Someone says it correctly.
Why would I want to be fair?
I'm facing you.
Oh my god, the fucking dropkick!
Wait, who is feeding Neurosama?
I mean, you're facing my dad, so to speak.
Not really my dad, though.
Oh, okay, this is a little bit embarrassing for Zend.
Not gonna lie.
I mean, look at them!
She's getting beat up by a little girl!
No, look, it's it's Summer Homeless Guy.
You're over a little chair!
Oh!
And Zintrea is stunned!
place you'll see these homeless guys is in your nightmares
and at why not's house of course how is she doing i have
already been seeing him standing outside my house actually i
haven't paid him yet oh no i hope that doesn't start to
affect your lovely personality oh i think nirosama got
another chair i think it's over for zen he's gonna break i
think it's over so the power of the eye a man in your house
couldn't be bad for you could it another chair i mean look
somebody anybody i know my math skills are top stop this
battle right now we it's not even legal we don't even have a
referee in here to call it the elevator okay how tall are
you i can't express my height in a number small enough to be
within your understanding, Zantreya, but you are correct.
Oh my god, how, why is the elevator?
Okay, please take the elevator back to the ring!
Without shoes, I'm around 4 feet 11 inches.
I'm still a girl, though.
Oh my gosh.
Nero-Sama is stunned.
This is it.
Is this it?
Is this over?
Does Zantreya have the advantage here.
I can literally just pick you up.
The cameraman is trying.
There's only one camera!
It's literally the backstage!
This wasn't supposed to happen!
Oh, and Zen's got her in the liglock now.
Also what do you think of my so-called dad?
As someone who doesn't have parents, they look pretty good
to me.
Not sure what they think of you, though.
I suspect they'll be disappointing.
Let this happen.
I can't believe it.
I don't want to join a group that you're a part of.
You and your dad must be having to balance anger between
each other and not throwing up after realizing the person
you're talking to is such a disaster.
Oh my god, the leg lock!
Look at her go!
Perhaps me and your father have more in common than we
think.
Did she call uncle?
I think it's over.
Get on top of her, Nero!
Nero come on you're so close bring her back to the elevator
take her home oh what there's a second floor I'm too
powerful you won't see me coming he tapped out it should be
over oh that's a little girl
is this over think about elevators I don't know what to
think about elevators.
They kind of just move up and down on a string.
There is no rep.
Who's gonna call this?
Nero won!
Zentrea actually called it to be over!
But yet she continues to fight!
You're kind of beating up my dad quite a bit.
How does that make you feel?
It doesn't faze me in the slightest.
Oh my god.
Oh, and the winner is!
really my dad so if you actually do see my dad sent him my
way please maybe if you ask him to teach you more math he
might show up ladies ladies please this was supposed to be
in the ring ladies but congratulations out of a homeless guy
congratulations to nero salma for the winner of the show
match back behind the scenes it was a battle of wits and i
just had too many what and what would you like to say for
yourself zen losing to a little girl hey zentrea don't take
it too hard everyone sucks in their first match well well
ladies thank you for being here that homeless guy
weren't even able to win the fight.
I don't think you should be paying anybody, Zen.
I don't think you should be paying anybody when the homeless
guy lost to a little girl who's not even real.
Save me.
Hey, Dokobird.
Don't pretend like you're a million times better than me.
Zintreya, I came out on top once.
I can do it again.
Damn.
You're gonna let her talk to you like that, Zen?
She's definitely got spirit.
well thank you zen and nero for being here for the very
first show match um honestly i not expect you guys to do
this behind without the refs uh refs there or behind the
backstage but congratulations to nero samma for winning the
first belt of the day uh i'm gonna take it back to the
casting the homeless man is crazy as fuck so i can't think
we both won here i mean nero beat neural one against the
homeless man Zen I think we all know who's the real loser
here that was properly scripted bird universe whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa this is a real wrestling event there is no
scripted here guys how dare you out the integrity of
WrestleTuber does not allow scripted events anyway guys I'm
gonna go back to the cast Yeah, but homeless man laying on
the ground Bleeding out is totally scripted Anyway EY Clark,
you owe me for this one We should call the Ambulance real
quick to help out that Homeless man, but let's take it back
To the casting table Thank you again to Nero and Zen for
being There for the very first match Of the day I'm gonna go
back to the casting table now Thank you again to those to
the ladies here Alright We're gonna be Back to the main
stage.
Wow.
All right.
That was unexpected.
Very unexpected, of course.
Who would have thought that our first fight would be the
backstage brawl without the refs?
It was having two absolutely strong ladies fucking decking
it out on each other.
um but of course uh since we got our first show match of the
it's not scripted guys wrestling is real uh i don't know why
uh why you guys would think it's why you guys think it's
scripted because we all know wrestling is very much uh uh
real guys um but yes i guess with that out of the way We are
in for our very first tournament bracket.
If you guys forgot, this will be the bracket for today.
Our first matchup will be with Lyme versus Kai.
I believe they will be there soon.
Again, like a huge shout out to Nero and Nero and Zen for
being there for the first show match.
But I'm really looking forward to our first match of the
day.
And it's going to be really exciting to see who's going to
win the...
It's crazy.
You guys all thought Nero's going to win anyway.
None of you believe in Zen?
I can't believe it.
But it feels weird that this seat is empty, though.
I wonder where is...
My co-cat.
Oh, shit!
Okay, what the fuck?
What was that?
Hello?
Sav?
What was that?
Kept you waiting, huh?
This wrestling ring is already haunted by the champion, Doki
Bird.
Okay, security?
Dude.
Security.
I thought I said no crashes tonight.
What the fuck was that?
How did they get here?
Hello?
I don't know how I could have made that any more clear here
Wait, where do I go?
I'm just, I'll die Okay
All right, let me Let me move a little bit Is this scene
taken?
Okay, all right, let me Clearly I have to move Let me move
too You're a little close to me Yeah, you get away from me
first I gave you I gave you the instructions how to appear I
was no I you were talking to security we were even talking
to me I didn't realize my mistakes now yeah yeah yeah well I
didn't need to be as big as your head holy shit okay let me
i guess i'll move a little bit over to yeah yeah all right
yes i have a co-caster it's not scripted everything is
authentic just like the real real wrestling wrestling is
very much real basically i was like busted down the door you
know i killed a man to get here you're a ghost you can just
phase through like that's the easiest answer you can say
that's so boring this is wrestling true wait you're right
sorry you're right murder is better than just phasing in
you're you're so right yes are you ready for the very first
matchup of the day mint i am do you even remember what the
first matchup was uh yeah i yeah i was uh yeah um it's live
and it's kai am i right
you're so right oh wait now we have to scoot back over yeah
give me a skim us i told the guys to stay one we're we're
experiencing some i totally like oh yeah you need me to hold
on yeah i need you to move a little bit more yeah i mean
you're a ghost it makes sense you know exactly exactly ghost
all right why don't we drop by into the interview channel
and hear the ladies out before our first first game starts
why don't we all right i'll see you there in the in the
interview room mint all right all right
Hello!
Are you ready to interview the two girls?
Yes, I'm not biased or anything.
Oh yeah, who do you want to win?
I'm Lyme.
Lyme?
But isn't like Kai like in your same company?
No.
Oh yeah, you should tell them to get over here.
That's your job, Juno.
That's the interviewer.
Oh, that's my job.
That's also your job.
Can I just like, I'll be right back.
Nobody knows what they're doing here, don't they?
What kind of show are you running?
There were volunteers, okay?
Nobody was...
You didn't even know what you were doing when we gave the
instructions out.
You can't say that!
Please.
They're here.
Welcome!
That was so stupid!
Hello!
Let's go!
How do you feel?
How do you guys feel for your first match?
Oh, sorry, Juno, that's your job.
That's my job, ma'am.
Excuse me.
Oh, she's a big bitch.
No, I'm sorry.
Um, hi, ladies, as the first matchup of the day, how are you
guys feeling?
I'm really hoping that it's a nice quick match because, you
know, it sucks to hurt people.
And also, I'm really sleepy, so I'd like to go to bed.
Oh, okay.
But this is, are you implying that you're going to beat her
quickly?
Bro, I can't speak.
I'm so sorry.
But are you implying that?
I'm going to deliver like 500 kilograms of pain and then I'm
going to go to sleep.
Oh, damn.
Hi, what's your response to that?
My response is, listen, I know your games, all right?
You're going to play nice, and then you think that's going
to make me go easy on you?
We'll take again.
All right, your name is Limu, all right?
I'm going to take those limes, all right?
I'm going to cut in half, and I'm going to squirt them on
your eyeballs, and then I'm going to take another line, and
I'm going to squirt them on my own eyeballs, and then you're
going to eat her ass?
No.
You're going to eat her ass?
Wait, wait, what?
You're free?
Beat, beat us and beat us and beat us.
I heard eat too.
Did you hear eat?
No.
Yeah.
I heard eat.
I'm hungry now.
I mean, you simply woke up the competition by doing
something so goddamn strange.
Let's go.
You know what?
Maybe that is the way to go.
Just do something so bizarre that your opponent is just so
confused.
I've never heard of lime and ash as like a meal, you know?
Really?
I mean, it's a delicacy.
I know what mint's gonna do tonight.
Give it her ideas, oh my god.
Don't act like you haven't tried it before, Doki.
How did you know that?
All right, ladies.
So, all right, I guess we're going to start the first match
of the bracket.
Good luck to you, too.
The loser will be back in the interview chair.
So, and I believe Juno wishes to talk to Kai after.
Yeah, it's going to be Kai.
Okay, fine.
We'll see.
see all right then i'm gonna go back to the casters room
we'll see you guys there in the ring good luck to you ladies
good luck all right let me swap to that game real quick
we're we're definitely misaligned oh that's so beautiful
look it's just you know day one and day two it'll be a lot
better we swear day two will be a lot better it's just you
know it takes there's like production stuff at the moment
you know while it's like while it's like getting the
wrestlers all together I cannot wait for you to see Axel's
Axel's one is Oh boy.
Okay.
All right.
There was... Wait, where's the intro?
No!
Guys, sorry.
Sorry.
Day one, Scott.
They're so nervous.
They just wanted to get fighting.
Yeah, they just wanted to get straight into it.
We apologize.
Wait, what was the legendary move that you were waiting to
see, Doki?
The legendary move?
Oh, yeah.
The handy dandy.
Do you think we're going to see...
Do you think we're going to see it tonight?
we haven't seen the handy dandy in 10 years yes in 10 years
it's gonna be so interesting if they pull it out guys i know
it'll be a really special special match a special match oh
my god the illegal handy dandy move wait life's actually
fucking over kai right now i don't know what's going i don't
know wait is this what the ass eating is like is this she's
delivering the lime she's putting the lime juice inside yeah
juicer lime juicer juicer oh my god she's bringing her up oh
jump jump jump oh oh oh oh it's okay it was a you know a
dominance thing yeah yeah it's not ready it's not over yet
it's not right oh hey there's the other casters over there
Who cares about those guys?
Yeah, who cares about them?
You pay for V-Tubers, and we're giving you V-Tubers.
V-Tubers.
Oh, my God.
Limes threw her back into the ring already.
She's not done yet, though.
I'm really loving Kai's top.
Honestly, I know.
Where did she get that?
It's so magical.
I heard she makes her own clothes.
What?
Yeah.
I mean, it looks like she made it herself Is that a car?
I can't tell That's a compliment or
Oh, and a kick to the face Please, she can't afford plastic
surgery I mean, if Lyme wants the plastic surgery She's
gonna have to win Oh, that's true The champion belt includes
Five whole dollars as well So she Whoa, five whole dollars
big money big money over here big money oh that pin oh my
god they're leaving they're leaving are they allowed to do
that mint i think i think well they don't i guess not maybe
they hurt you they were like oh my god and another flip from
lime i'm hoping to see lime tear out kai's um chest hair
That's true.
She needs to shave.
Yeah.
Like, oh, and then a pin?
Oh.
That's unfortunate.
Come on, get her ass.
Oh, my.
Hey, you remember that move?
That move is very familiar.
For some reason, I felt like I've seen that move before in a
dream.
Maybe you hit your head.
many times because of it what the fuck is she doing oh my
god oh my god what she's really dragging her up to the into
the middle there why is she rotating her in the middle just
ended already they're just playing with each other they're
just they're just meals they're each other's food it's like
the appetizer yeah come on juicer come on oh Wait, is Lime a
Furry?
She's had that tail on.
Look at that tail, though.
No.
It's a petty shot.
We see where Mint's eyes are going, too.
Hey, good thing you don't have an eye tracker.
That's so untrue.
Oh, another flip.
Another flip.
little flippy they're feeling okay come on come on end this
right now kai it's so easy look she broke her arm oh it's
ready for the pin one two guys please guys come on you guys
can't keep beating each other up ladies i'm telling you they
just like to play around with each other that's true it's
like poor play they're both sadists and masochists
you're giving the people what they want oh no i think the
people in the front row look kind of bored hey get excited
people what's wrong with you what's wrong with you you got
all the panty shots in the world yeah i'll see you what i
don't know what the fuck is this going on no we're casters
we know exactly what that Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, that was...
You first.
It was totally...
The London Bridge.
The London Bridge is falling down, ladies and gentlemen!
But who will fall first?
Who will fall first?
Oh, hey, anyway, sponsored by Gamer Subs down there.
Thank you, Gamer Subs!
Thank you!
Gotta get that in there.
Use any gamer's subcode.
They've already paid for this.
Oh my god, another bet.
Oh, wait, why did she stop?
I don't know.
Oh, she's just...
What the hell?
She just like...
What the?
Kai just took it.
Like, Kai just literally got it.
in position to take that yeah what is she doing why is she
rotating her into the middle get up kai this is not soccer
oh my god that is a fancy okay lime at this point just just
come on and this come on lime stop dragging just over on top
of her lime come on oh oh the finishing move here it is She
missed.
How did you miss Lime?
She was right there.
Kai was just regaining a little bit of energy.
But, oh.
Oh, she's getting back up.
Oh, she's getting that energy from the crowd.
She's hyping everybody up.
It's like, give me your energy.
It's just like Dragon Ball.
We're like, give me your energy.
Raise your hands in the air and give me the energy.
Raise your hands, everybody.
Raise your hands.
One, two.
Oh, you didn't give enough energy, and it's your fault,
chat.
Oh, dang.
What the fuck?
That is not safe.
No, they could have hit someone outside the ring with that.
I know.
They don't care.
They probably say Tuscaru.
Again, again.
We love seeing anime girls cry.
Do it again.
What the fuck?
Holy shit.
That's swing.
They better get back in the ring soon, though.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
She's going to leave.
She's going to leave Kai out there.
Yeah, take her out and leave her down.
Six.
Oh, six.
Come on, we'll see her.
Come on, Kai.
Get back in the ring.
Are you really going to get disqualified?
Okay, okay.
Oh, oh, what?
Okay, I mean, like, I get that like a sea.
I feel like I just watched, like, a cheerleading
competition.
That's true.
oh wait a second is that another pen is this it could it be
could it be mine come ref what are you doing oh here is your
winner the juicy lime delicious
yeah thank you announcer don't worry we're gonna turn on the
intros later next one oh i think lime needs to go to the
chiropractor oh my god lime is the chiropractor did you not
see what we saw just then yeah i guess it's a hidden talent
you know it's uh oh my gosh she is the yeah i feel like
she's gonna get a lot of customers tonight after this that's
for sure oh i guess i guess we're gonna go talk to the
losers i guess okay all right here let's go to the interview
stage and
quick hello hello it's okay how'd it feel getting boggy a
team by limu like five times girl that's right and now i
gotta take my ass to a fucking kai reprint okay that was
okay you gotta admit those are some fucking insane flips i'm
sorry that was
real fucking leverage, bro.
I don't understand.
Are you a bird?
You're not a lion.
It's ferret agility.
Don't worry about it.
We got no bones.
Oh, I want to talk about your move where you, like, bounced
three times and then, like, front-fliped into her stomach.
That was incredible.
Oh, yes, please.
Describe what was going through your throat.
Yeah, my ribs!
I liked all the I liked all the moves specifically where it
kind of just looked like I was giving you a nice stretch.
It's like, I'm sorry for kicking you in the face, Queen,
here.
Let me just quickly, like, you know.
give your back a little bit of a stretch out is that better
no no no i would have rather you beat my ass instead of this
fucking embarrassment dragging me around the ring all right
you lift you i'm sorry yeah you could have looked you said
to break my ribs yeah that that makes sense you lost to a
girl who couldn't even lift you kai that's wow i tried i
tried to have a cutback like agility too yeah you can't just
put it all on strength there i really did like the part
though where i climbed up on the side of the ring and then
tried to like pull you up to do something and then kind of
just gave up because you're returning i've been bulking i'm
bulking i'm bulking i guess the whole thing is for you to
stop bulking kind of that's that's a more less you want to
be more more mashed it's harder for her to like you know
carry me around all right yeah but then it's also harder for
you to move your own limbs kai but but i have like
protection no you definitely didn't have protection if your
ribs are broken don't don't judge my ways okay there's a
method to my madness you guys just don't understand nobody
understands me nobody gets me man congratulations for moving
on to the next stage unfortunately that means you're gonna
be awake anyway
why would you want to sleep when you can beat more ass you
know exactly yeah beat us and eat us i couldn't sleep with
all this adrenaline anyway exactly i mean you won lime you
won yeah i just have one request if rin if rin wins please
kick her ass Yes, please, please, please.
If she wins, please.
My last request, you.
I will do my very best.
I will try to honor your dying request as you just lie on
the ground, like, with your face stomped and your balls
crushed.
Whoa.
All right.
Lucky for you guys.
Rin and Emma will be next in the bracket.
You know, we might as well just stay here in the interview
room while the too late, the loser and the winner should
leave.
and drag in the other two ladies.
Okay, okay, true.
We're behind schedule, guys.
All right.
Okay, that's all.
Oh, she do.
Yes, they try.
Okay, good.
You're the very first loser here.
All right.
Can we get Emma and Rin into the interview?
Oh, my God.
The babies.
Hello.
Wow.
you guys yeah where am i how did i get here um we kidnapped
you yeah i i blacked out and then i opened my eyes and
there's like blaring music and very bright lights and tuna
unagi for some reason so i'm a little bit discombobulated
help yeah welcome to my cave reen penrose you are going to
defeat a final dungeon boss right now i feel about that i
can give you advice on how Oh no, no, no, no that kind of
advice!
What are your information?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
Is this what I'm thinking?
No, that kind of, no, that kind of...
Are we not thinking about it?
Meant to you?
No, that kind of advice!
I don't know about it.
I think, oh my goodness.
You're gonna be a little under the table action going on
here.
Yeah, Gina, what is it?
Uh, Renu should deafen?
You should deafen me?
I feel like it's a topic I need to deafen for.
Maybe it doesn't need to be said on live streaming.
The great thing is that this isn't TV.
No, I gave you an out and everything.
Well, let's just say Rin today is going to be raiding some
dungeons tonight.
I don't think any of that is going to be happening
personally.
Will the British be coming, you know?
Oh, the British be coming.
I think the British are going to be going straight into
another grave, guys.
Well.
Any smack talk?
all I sense is confusedness and confusion.
Yeah, I guess you're talking.
If I wasn't scared before, I'm very scared now.
Thank you.
No, it's okay, Rin.
You can just show me your little sword over here and sleep
with me.
What?
Wait, she's a prince!
Like, she has a sword with!
She has a sword with her!
Must be?
You, you're a little prince.
She has a sword with you, right?
Salt?
I'm very confused.
RID!
You have a sword!
Come on, RID!
A sword!
A freaking sword!
What kind of sword I'm talking about!
Your sword!
Everyone yelling at me!
RID is just, it's like, RID is like this little confused boy
at a supermarket.
He's like, we're so involved.
I'm scared!
Your mom's with me, Rin.
Oh, that'd be for fast, because that's the Superbike!
Oh, you always were my favorite one, you were knocking.
Yes.
I hope y'all duke it out.
I honestly don't know who I want to win.
Okay, no, Juno, consider, consider.
If I win, wait, shit, no, Kai lost, never mind.
Yeah.
Now, I was kind of hoping that I'd be able to face off
against Kai, but you know what?
It's okay.
Next time.
Are you just accepting it?
She just gave up.
Yeah, I was just like, are you guys just giving up?
Like, what is this?
Yeah, you just gave up me.
You know.
Come on, Rene.
Where's the passion, Rene?
Give us the passion.
Uh, I'm, I'm, I'm gonna, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh.
She's British and has no emotion.
I love this.
I'm feeling it already.
I'm feeling something.
I feel something.
I mean, you could guess it.
Who knows?
it's okay read i'll i'll eat fish and chip with you after
this okay we'll make oh in her dungeon in her time no it's
just a fish and chips good all right good luck ladies we are
now going to go back to the main stage and we'll see who's
gonna who's gonna survive the dungeon raid
Lord, help us all.
I'll see you ladies later.
All right.
Let us, we have the votes.
And currently, Ryn is actually winning the poll at the
moment, which is very surprising after what we saw in the
interview.
It's always the ones that are most timid, though, you know.
That's so true.
They're hiding, like, their power level.
Exactly, exactly.
Yeah, you're right.
You're right.
They're hiding their power level.
Like, you don't know, you don't know what's going to happen.
Don't worry.
We have the intro this time around.
I did not forget it this time.
I apologize to Don't worry.
Lime made it through so we can see Lime's intro later.
Like, oh, true, true.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So it'll be all right.
All right.
We're starting the match.
John VTuber.
John Renn VTuber.
I like how she has a green screen on so, like, her fans
could insert, you know, whatever they want down there.
Or they could just Just have the body disappear.
Yeah, yeah.
It's just a floating head.
Yeah, that's true.
Okay.
The following contest is scheduled for one fall.
Introducing first.
Oh my gosh, this is a long entry.
The long area.
Oh!
Someone's dilemma.
Umia Emma.
Oh my gosh, she has a crown.
She's like royalty.
The claws, the crown, this is...
Is that legal?
Can she bring those claws to the ring?
But you know, fancy get up gives you no tactical advantage
whatsoever.
But like, do you not see her hands?
Like, yeah, what do you mean?
Stab her in the eye.
That's what I'm saying.
She can just stab her in the fucking eye.
Oh, Your Majesty, please, come in.
Oh, my God.
I mean...
Whoa, in a little battle for us.
Your Majesty.
No wonder so many people are coming into your dungeon in
more ways than one.
I don't know what you mean by that.
And introducing their opponents.
Oh.
oh my god that's so british the brit i don't know i'm gonna
win rin and rose
this truly is the british are coming the british are coming
everybody i love how she brought like an inflatable duck
with her like a little floaty yeah that's gonna do anything
with someone with sharp nails like everything is glowing i
think they're like you know the real gamer gamer wrestler
over here wait she also has a crowd oh my god is it it's
gonna be like a wrestling wedding the king and queen i was
thinking wait what wedding yeah like the royal wedding okay
oh my
Oh my god Holy shit, she's so tall!
Oh my god Oh my god!
I will not help you in this Viva la revolution!
Let's go!
That's French!
Wrong country mint France is across the ocean!
Okay, well, what do you mean across the ocean and it's
technically across and the british look out into the ocean
across from them is france they're still connected by land
no they're not british is a fucking island they're on this
it's europe there's the same continent the uk is on the
island do you not know the uk is on an island oh wait you're
right You know what?
I shouldn't be surprised.
You in geography, I shouldn't race.
What do you mean by that?
And you live as well, okay?
Oh, yeah, you know all the flags in the world.
This is why the British are losing.
You didn't even know the UK was an island.
Hey, I'm a ghost.
I've been dead for so long.
I only remember Pangaeo.
Oh, so you're at the Teutonic Plates.
Things are shifting still.
still shifting she lives in the past and the present guys
exactly time has no concept to her oh my god what wait the
british almost pinned her
wait why why didn't emma bring her claws like it should be
so easy oh my god oh my god that's
not stopping she's just going she's going at it yeah like
crazy oh oh rin took some crazy hits there i don't i think
like rin chose the wrong dungeon that's for sure i think so
too i mean level level one mafia versus level 99 mafia is
this even legal you're doing it all the ring ladies oh oh my
god she's just like beating her up outside the ring she does
not care no oh the she's out for blood yeah inside i'm i'm
surprised that like um surprise oh my okay did you trip she
just tripped on her own feet instead of her fall it's so one
excited what do you mean we literally saw grin get absolute
pulverized yeah size is not everything yeah size is not the
agility yeah exactly oh wait already someone quick cgi right
now oh oh there's another pin one one two three and is
actually here is your winner someone's dilemma Emma okay
that is sort of like really embarrassing though for the
match before it lasted like 20 years yeah you know the
British are just you know their fighting style is too polite
I think the Viva Revolution sort of jinxed the whole thing.
Do you want to try that again?
Oh my god, another item member got wiped out.
That's a little sad.
I guess we're going to go to the interview stage to talk to
you.
Yeah, let's see what Rin feels like about all of this.
Hello.
That was the fastest match yet.
That was the first...
This is the second match.
That was the first one though.
Oh, Rin, how did it feel?
I don't...
Like, I saw you, like, get...
I think she's funny.
I think we need an ambulance.
If anyone out there can call, I don't know what it is in the
UK, but it's 1-1-9.
I have seven concussions.
Sorry, I accidentally punched her too much because she's so
funny with that green suit.
I can't.
I was snorting so hard.
It was like when a bull sees red.
You saw green and you just- How many times do you have to
punch me for it to stop?
Because you act!
She was giving you CPR, if I- You know what they say?
The taller they are, the harder they fall.
So, Rin Penrose, how does it feel not being in the neck?
Painful!
Physically, I- I think my ribs are misaligned.
I think, um, I mean, that's part of the contract, you know?
So- you know what you are getting here.
I think, like, you know, when we saw you in the ring, we
noticed that was not your accurate height there.
So, like, somebody was wearing heels there.
John V-Tuber.
Yeah, John V-Tuber, what are you doing wearing those high
heels in the wrestling match?
Oh, have you...
No, please go ahead.
Healies.
That was so strange.
Well, about how did it feel beating up the Rin Penrose?
Uh, good.
I'm still in the room, you know?
It's so fast.
I thought she can beat me harder, but...
Gosh, maybe because you're British, I guess.
You know, like, there's stamina.
Every bone in my arms are broken, Emma.
Yeah, because apparently...
I thought British people are so powerful.
I can't believe you're that.
Yeah, it's very...
I am a small victim.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
It's okay.
I'll heal you with a cup of tea.
Call 119.
999.
What are the numbers?
What are the three numbers?
What do they mean?
There's too many emergency numbers.
966.
999.
six and nine nine all right congratulations to emma for
making it to the next round your opponent uh will be limu
soon after after uh our next match but anyway as we want to
say thank you again to emma and rin for joining us rin
you're sadly you're the second loser of the night another
idol has been eliminated from the bracket Come on, idol
girls.
Come on, idol girls.
So, we have actually, we have one more idol girl, right?
How many more of, we have two idol girls left.
So, we have Juna and Fuyo left to represent Idol.
So, I wonder if Fuyo will win against Snuffy later.
I guess we'll finally see.
We'll finally see.
Anyway, we're going to have to kick you girls out and move
on to the next pair.
The biggest match of the night.
Oh.
Oh, yes.
Yeah.
The meteor and the dinosaur.
Nana, kick his ass!
Thank you so much, guys!
All right, see you later, girls.
Can we drag in the next two?
Go get some help, Rin.
Yeah, go get some help.
She definitely needs it.
I can't drag.
Oh, wait, I should give you...
You know, I should give you admin.
Permissions, please.
Please, please.
I told you, day one, it's all about figuring stuff out,
guys.
I grew.
All right, you can ask them for now, but I'm going to give
you admin room.
All right.
Nana is saying, oh, hot, good God, ah, good, good, I think
she's nervous.
I think she's throwing up.
Yeah, a little bit.
We're throwing up, but she made, she merely made, like, a
diss track before.
There we go.
Oh, my God.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Hello.
So, I've been seeing the beef on Twitter.
We finally talk face to face.
Nana.
Oh my God.
I just, let me just say right now you fucking dropped the
diss track right before.
Right before the actual match.
How fucking damn you?
Wait.
It's been 65 million years, Gerard.
How we've been doing getting pregnant, I hear.
What?
You've been doing your research.
I see.
The galaxy never disappoints.
You've always been watching me.
I know you have three children who live under a bridge with
no mom, no dad, and you eat grime.
That is none of your business.
Keep your nose out of my life.
You tried to ruin mine.
Now get out of it.
I'm trying to live peacefully here.
Oh, are you crying?
Don't try to ruin it.
Are you crying?
I'm not crying.
I'm trying to live, and I can't believe we're matched up.
I just want to live, man.
Like, what is this?
This got to be rigged.
It has to be rigged.
am i fighting you i could have been fighting anyone else why
am i fighting you god damn it i'm remembering traumatic
experiences from my childhood ladies i have a question for
you jorad jorad jorad i have a question for you mahogany or
oak mahogany okay good that's gonna be the coffin i'm gonna
put you in six oh son of a bitch what oh no i i can't bury
you you're literally the I don't know.
I don't know how to make a comeback about that.
I'll just try my best.
Holy fuck.
Stop.
I'm already dead.
The match hasn't even started yet.
He's crying, Chad.
He's crying.
Guys, guys, cheer me on.
Please, this is the only means of me actually fighting back.
He needs the money from the tournament to pay for child
support.
I heard you have a diss track that you made about Gerard.
Can you give us a little sneak peek?
How many hours did it take you to, like, make that?
Holy shit.
I made that song in 10 hours since last night.
Oh, that was last minute!
That sounded so great, though.
Holy shit, I thought that would, like, take a day.
Holy crap.
Oh, thank you.
Oh, do you like it?
That's some pure fucking rage out there.
What the fuck did I do to you?
Why do you have to roast me like that?
That wasn't necessary.
I thought that would have been fucking enough.
Acapella of the roast for us, the disc track.
Acapella.
Oh, by the way, the beat is like completely like made of
customs.
So you can play it.
Oh, my God.
Girard, what the fuck were you doing?
This is why the Astro Whitefield tie down.
Like, what the fuck?
I got nothing.
I was just starting beef.
And then I didn't know you'd be making a disc track.
I didn't think that was a thing.
Girard, what were you doing?
It's been five million years.
What were you doing, okay?
While I was being born from the galaxy.
Live!
Try to live!
After that massacre of my family, you think I'd be doing
something against the galaxy?
Nothing!
I'm just trying to live!
Prioritizing my own life!
Pick it up!
What were you doing?
That is why she came back to finish the job, guys.
She noticed Geron was wasting his life after the chance she
gave him to live on.
She noticed he was wasting his life, so she's coming back to
finish the job.
No, but I will be winning today.
as the movie ends with me being the victor everyone dies but
not everyone lives their life i think you're we got some
wise words from the galaxy herself i can't tell if you're
praising me or you're kidding me pick up i feel like we've
already i mean i can't help it you dropped the district i
can't help be humble i i gotta be humbled holy i i gotta i
gotta put in some work you did some good oh i'm trying my
tiny arms can't it's wailing how much money more money
ladies come take this to the ring ladies the polls are
actually pretty surprisingly close not as actually only has
a 57 percent of winning this match from the audience vote so
that's really crazy to see after you know you're out getting
his ass beat verbally so You may have cooked me in the
distract section, in the beef section, but this time, I'm
going to be putting you down in a real match.
Nana, prepare your ass.
You're still going down.
Big to my shooting saw press, Gerard.
I'll see you there.
Oh, God.
Enough.
Why are you dissing me?
Okay.
Stop speaking my language.
It hurts even more.
It hurts.
See you in the ring.
See you guys in the ring.
We're going to join back the caster's table now.
that shit was crazy though though oh my god they were going
out that was like a beef worth a million years not gonna lie
i feel like i feel like i just watched uh gerard turn into
like coal it was just under that pressure i know like
honestly i would be very surprised that gerard managed to
pull this off after what we saw today i mean even even even
nana's guy look at her just giving salt bay yeah right like
a dress just like expectations.
T-Rash is like, I'm happy to be here.
Gee, Willikers.
Yeah.
I mean, it could, everything could be lighting a fire under
his butt, you know?
That's true.
We don't know how he's going to react.
It's all, it's good.
It's anyone's game.
Yeah, yeah.
I just, it feels like he's like, you know, it feels like he
has like suspenders on and he's like, oh, geezer.
I'm so happy.
He just had a golden ticket to go to Williwatt.
He's trying.
He's like, golly cheese, sir.
I'm so happy to be here.
I got the golden ticket to be in Wrestle Tubing.
The following contest is scheduled for one fall.
Introducing first.
Oh, who's it gonna be?
Oh, yes, yes.
It's Na Na.
Oh, she's back.
She's back to finish.
Oh my gosh, she's famous.
I mean, The asteroid that killed off the dinosaurs.
That's a pretty famous asteroid.
Not gonna lie That is that is And also pretty old.
So yeah, a hag.
Yeah, kind of a hag.
Yeah, I thought you like that I mean as one I would hope You
gotta support your own kind, you know It's self-loves
You gotta support your own kind man You got to send one of
them over.
Yeah, exactly.
Introducing their opponent.
Whoa.
They painfully adored.
Girard T.
Rexford.
What the?
Whoa.
He is definitely lost.
He's like, this isn't the factor.
Yeah.
Where's my golden ticket?
Where's Willie?
Oh, he's crawling.
He's crawling.
Oh, my God.
Wild animal.
What a freak.
I thought, I don't think, I don't think T-Rex has used their
friend's hand.
He's already doing it wrong.
He's just like, where's Charlie?
Where's Willy Wonka?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, okay.
that pose sir yeah for the fan confidence king i know the
last remaining dinosaur where did he get oh what the hell he
got a chain he got a chain who's the kid here who let this
man have a chain so oh the pyrotechnics oh my god he went
all out he went all out with this yeah but a budget doesn't
mean you know a brain we'll see or let's see i mean t-rex is
known to have like a tiny brain they're like chickens true
yeah all birds have tiny brains yeah i'm proof of that we
know we know oh shit the asteroids are ready striking down
wow i'm not a good start for gerard that's for sure it's
like she's taking she's finishing the job what should have
been done millions of years ago i know she wanted him to
live a full life to remember all his fam that his fat what
the fuck is wrong with his neck oh my god did you see that
it was like a 180.
oh oh he's gonna pull his tail gerard please do something
gerard do something your family died for this oh there we go
there we go he was just playing it he was keeping it cool he
was that's true that's you had the upper hand he wanted he's
like rigging the bets right now so more people bet against
him yeah yeah i just oh oh oh where she goes hey you almost
hit the imposter and announcers yeah the the extras yeah the
extras the filthy flushies
Who invited the 3D people in a 2D tournament?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Keep her anime, get this out.
Not anime, leave.
Alright, this seems like...
Where is she grabbing?
HR?
He is putting his hands somewhere that he should not be.
It's kind of beautiful, like a little princess carry.
That is true.
Do you want to be carried?
like that um like right
do you want to be a princess I'm the maid to the princess oh
so you'll do the carrying I see you want to be the carrier
oh my god she's just watching him look the crowd is going
nuts several people are saying this is awesome it is pretty
awesome She shit won a pin!
Wow, wow, wait!
Oh my god!
Here is your winner!
Yes!
It's no!
No!
That's just sad.
Okay, gotta call bullshit, bullshit!
That never happened!
I think you were enjoying that a little bit, Gerard.
I think you were enjoying that.
No!
All she did was just pin it.
Slap his ass.
All of her.
That was so embarrassing.
Holy shit.
All right, let's talk to the loser real quick.
Yeah.
Well, that was...
That was...
I mean, but was he actually losing?
Come on.
I think it was...
It was...
We just had to let him go at that point.
It was just too much.
All right, off to the interview stage, we go.
All right.
You're a fucking sweet though.
Bro, I put it on my actual...
Oh my gosh.
I put my actual statistics there.
My height and everything.
And I was fighting this big brawling dude.
I didn't know!
Oh.
They say it was a canon event.
Well, that was embarrassing.
Well, this track is actually true now.
I got buried.
And that's the casket.
Uh, Mahogany?
Was it?
Gosh!
Well, it's okay, Geron.
was handicapped with pregnancy he's expecting i was fighting
a galaxy to be to be fair i was i was fighting the galaxy
and um it was it it was like a huge power gap and uh you
know i okay i give up you literally have millions of years
to prepare for it like yeah but i didn't be thinking i'd be
fighting it in a wrestling match i thought i'd be fighting
it somewhere else where like where i don't know a few
million more years i i i'm just 21 years old okay i don't
know You're a fetus dinosaur.
What the fuck?
I was fighting a galaxy.
I was just a teeny little bit dinosaur.
Shout out to sorority for helping me build my absolute
weapon.
Even my fucking blue.
Even my fans.
Thank you, sorority.
Thank you, galaxy games.
I love you.
God love you.
And this is historically accurate.
The last dino has been slain.
No.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I can't accept this.
Shut up, shut up, shut up, shut up!
Shut up!
Jirad, all I'm saying, Jirad, is that maybe you should have
worked on a diss track.
What?
That wouldn't help.
That's not helping me with my fucking build.
I'm fucking scrawny ass.
Literally was like powered up by her diss track.
Yeah.
You know, all I just want to say is that I'm satisfied.
I don't even need to win this game.
Yeah.
I feel my life goal has been satisfied.
Oh, the threats I've carried to 65 million years.
They've been settled.
I'm at peace.
I'm at Zen.
I've reached their point.
I am... I'm fucking annoyed.
I... I want to fight you again.
I need a rematch right now.
Oh, yeah?
I want to fight you again!
Ura!
You wanna go!
I'll fight you right now!
Ura!
I know what you did!
under the bridge i don't know where you live not my kids
they're watching no anywhere but there okay i know where you
live yeah i know where you live oh my god i would be
surprised if she didn't know where i live she's the galaxy
fuck's sake she just like destroys the earth and be like i
know where you live
it changed his world but for me It was a Tuesday I'm already
dead.
I'm already defeated.
Could you please stop?
I'm already dead
Ladies ladies go take this fight into Backstage because
we're gonna be letting in the next set of fights in bracket
one Yeah, but thank you.
Thank you for having us.
Thank you.
Thank you for organizing this.
Thank you Thank you!
Thank you, Duna!
Thank you!
You dated!
I'm so happy for you!
Bye-bye!
Goodbye, get out!
Get out!
All right.
Oh, so did you see the...
Yeah, yeah, I changed it.
All right.
I changed it.
Oh, my God.
I mean, yeah.
Do you like it?
I love it.
It's beautiful.
Okay, the issue right now is that Snuffy is offline.
So...
i don't know if i don't know if snuffy is here right now can
anyone impersonate snuffy okay we could go with limu versus
emma for now until snuffy appears snuffy is a little bit and
we don't know where she is oh but we're not for like fuyo so
will oh okay is fuyo okay waiting until snuffy appears
before oh we can i can ask i saw her on before yeah i
thought i saw her on she's Where did you go?
Okay, oh yeah, she's kind of waiting.
She's fine avoiding.
All right, okay, because of that, then we'll go with Lama
versus Emma then.
Okay, okay.
All right.
Please come back in, please.
Oh my god, checking Emma is so huge.
She like overtook them.
Why didn't you make me size accurate?
I'm actually seven foot tall.
yield you're not seven look at my wiki look at my wiki for
wiki yeah anybody can edit that wiki no but i haven't i had
a stream where i elongated to someone hello emma hello hello
how you guys wow yeah like that was so wow i love the energy
yeah it's okay i have a small power nap between my hands i'm
feeling a little bit better but i feel so funny the fact
that we both want lose but we both we know i don't know
who's going to lose over here oh no wait that didn't work
yeah who wants it more yeah who wants it more out of you two
guys i'm a once in more no wait i want it more how much do
you want to win oh you want to win now lime i thought you
want to lose no i i i i'm horribly competitive oh oh why i
see the burning passion in my voice of and and how
adrenaline filled i sound right now i'm just so fucking into
it dude you're like a natural have you read instructions on
how to beat a dungeon boss no no no no no no no no no no no
you didn't even hear this before yeah yeah yeah like min
doesn't know what you're talking about like never were able
to figure it out um well i think like over a hundred k
people know what i'm talking about 100k people raid your
dungeon why would they know i don't i don't understand why
would they know that what it's okay for not only live who
can rate my dungeon right live you will rate my dungeon
right hell yeah yeah over and over again yeah yeah yeah
Yeah, yeah, you can touch me in the face.
You can step on me.
You can do whatever you want, Lime.
Whoa!
She's a masochist.
You got this.
Oh my gosh.
I'm gonna get demonetized.
Well, it's on my channel, so like...
I'm gonna get you demonetized.
I'm already used to it.
I think we're ready to smash each other.
I guess... Whoa!
End game, end game, end game guys, please.
Oh yeah, obviously.
Come, take all this aggression.
My London Bridge.
Oh my God, bring back the London Bridge.
Bring back the London Bridge, it's falling down.
All right, ladies, we'll take all that aggression out on
each other in the fucking ring.
Was that aggression?
Or I want to do it.
Some people will call that aggression.
Yeah.
Oh, whoa.
Hey, good luck, ladies.
We're going to move to the main casting table now.
I'm just standing over here.
I'll see you guys there.
Good luck, ladies.
Good luck.
Hey, I did not make the poll yet for this match.
What are you doing, Don't you?
I was so busy listening to this conversation.
It was so interesting.
Were you not immersed?
No, you were just fantasizing about...
About what?
About raiding a dungeon.
And what does that mean?
Going on a grand journey.
Oh, true.
And finding treasure, you know?
Finding treasure.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And that's it, right?
And then becoming rich and famous.
Yeah.
That's what raiding is.
Find someone else's stuff and you steal it.
Yeah.
Yeah, steal their booty.
What else could it be?
Nah.
Alright.
Let's head over to Lymu versus Emma.
Actually, I don't know.
They both seem like both of them at the end of the other.
Well, Lymu actually had like a real fight, to be fair.
Yeah, Lymu, I think has been the longest match so far.
Yeah, the longest matchup we've seen so far.
The other is not so much.
I think she's just a little sleepy, but she said she had a
match.
I feel, yeah, but to be fair, they're like a natural.
I think Lyme was a natural wrestler.
Not gonna lie.
I think so too.
Emma, I mean, Emma fucking destroyed Rin, but like, but it
was Rin, so.
The following contest is scheduled for one fall.
That is round two.
Introducing first.
Oh my gosh, she's so Eepy.
Eepy.
What an Eepy, girl.
She just woke up from a nap.
She looks like she's like coming from Starbucks.
The juiciest piece of fruit lime.
Alicia.
She's like, I'm just gonna wake up and then.
Wake up and kick ass.
Let's go.
There are those like white girl quotes.
Like.
Is that a sleeping bag or is that the coffin that she'll be
burying?
Oh, it's a pillow.
it's a pillow wow this music is so like chill yeah it's like
lo-fi yeah and she beat kai what was that got her coffee in
her pillow she's ready she's ready introducing her opponent
it's your majesty someone's dilemma
Who's Dilemma, sir?
Emma!
Announceer, who's Dilemma is she, Announceer?
You never finished your question!
We'll never find out who's Dilemma she is.
Oh, well, I guess she's Limes, maybe.
We'll see.
I mean, I don't know.
understand why they can't endurance you know lime lime was
able to hold her own the whole time that's true that's true
even when she was like an epi baby she was able to what
would be i wish like you know w-e i should call somebody an
epi baby and over there she was an epi baby baby
mint needs a headset mint fucking crashed the event she does
not get a headset i did not prepare a headset yeah why don't
you give me one yeah this is mine i'm not supposed to be
here i'm here illegally she's an illegal ghost guys we
didn't summon you Let's go.
Okay.
Oh, what a hit.
Starting out strong.
And another hit too.
Whoa, she's just breaking her arm.
Maybe she's too EP.
Yeah, she's too EP.
Oh, my God.
Not the arm.
Please.
What's somebody think about her?
How is she going to drink her coffee without arms?
Oh, through a straw, I guess.
Yeah.
Doffy threw a straw like...
Oh my god, I can't get enough of these panty shots.
Mint, her chest is up there!
Her tail is back there!
Mint, you're gonna look at the panty shot when you have
Emma's chest right there for you.
I mean, that's true, that's true, but...
I mean, have you not seen her measurements?
It's more fun when it's flash, you know?
You just see it a little bit.
Take me to the HR training here.
Oh, holy shit.
What is going on here?
Is she just like, let me ponder your orb.
Whoa!
Right in the gut!
Oh my God.
I don't know what she was doing, measuring her cranium.
Yeah, she's like, I need to buy you a hat.
Let me measure.
I don't have a ruler.
I can't believe it.
I've never It's been 20 years since I saw The measure the
cranium move Sometimes I feel like it's a little Useless but
what do I know I think it's like a power move It's like to
just show that you can do it It's true It doesn't do
anything you just can do it One Two Oh And Limeo broke it
Limeo's endurance Like coming in clutch here Yeah so much
work right now she might be an ep baby but she knows what
she's doing yeah i feel emma is like very brutal but she's
gonna tire herself out you know yeah like i mean like she
clearly does not have long stamina unlike lime oh oh my god
oh my god just bring a knife while you're at and shake her
she had them on her fingers that's true remind her of london
take her back to her hometown i see london i see france i
see limu's underpants
there they are and another stop from them what was the move
that we were waiting for doki the handy dandy the handy
dandy we've seen it once before in this event the town it's
been banned for 10 years but these ladies they don't care
about laws neither do we neither do we yeah bring a knife
just shake her where's the london bridge oh and the slam
Two, Jesus Christ, that's her back.
And when you fuck your back up, Emma shows no mercy.
Yeah, Emma doesn't care.
Oh, right on the head?
Holy shit.
Oh, she's giving us what we want.
One, two.
Oh, oh.
It's not over here.
Yeah.
God moves like, no, no, no.
We gotta show it again.
Oh, a second time.
One, one, two.
Oh.
It's because the cameraman gave us the wrong angle.
You know?
Yeah, it's the truth.
Yeah, they got to do it again.
Guys, guys, the camera does not know what he's doing.
Like, we need a different egg.
Oh, my God, the grip!
Wait, and then the reversal?
And again!
Another pin?
One, two, three!
Oh, my God.
Emma is out of control.
She is, like, obsessed with the dungeon days.
Here is your winner, the big dilemma.
Oh, look at her go.
She's happy with another.
She has absorbed another dungeon raider.
Everybody's Dilemma.
Very good.
I didn't realize we were raiding.
I have three stars.
Let me put in the wrestling app real quick.
Three stars.
It needed a little bit more work, Emma.
I feel like, you know, you should have positioned her in a
better, better way so that the camera would get it, you
know?
Yeah, always know your angles, come on.
Yeah, exactly.
I always know where the camera is facing, Emma, if you want
a higher rating on WrestlingTuber app.
All right, let's go talk to the...
Could have been better, you know.
All right, let's go talk to the ladies real quick.
All right.
Yeah, you are.
Hello!
Welcome back!
Lymu, how do you feel being able to sleep now?
It's gonna be great.
Like, I think maybe I should have had some extra caffeine
and save the nap for after the match, but it's okay.
You live and learn.
You live and learn and then you get your skull crushed, but
it's okay.
Did you like, did you enjoy being, like, having your skull
crushed by the Emma?
Yeah, no, it was really good.
I'd do it again.
To be fair, you try, you might do it like several times.
times too she keep getting step on i feel so bad i was like
stop me stop it was consensual don't worry yeah she just
she's just an ego she want to go home and play valorant oh
gosh
so so how does it feel to lose against emma sorry judah
you're supposed to say that No, I said her like basically
because she wants to sleep.
I mean, I can reword my answer, I guess.
I mean, say again, but with different sentences.
So we didn't plagiarize.
Yeah, no, no, it was honestly, it was honestly an honor to
get stepped on by someone so tall and muscular.
This doesn't mean you would let Emma be your Discord daddy.
Yeah.
Oh, come here.
Come here, little Kieran.
You have to listen to your daddy right now.
It looks like this dungeon boss has conquered her own
dungeon.
Oh my god.
We're like listening to this live.
The role play goes crazy.
The role.
If you win the tournament, what will you do with your belt?
Me?
Yeah.
If I win?
I will show it to my dad.
I'm going to be so proud.
Why do you think we're so sultry with that?
It's like, if you win your belt, why are you...
If you win, what will you do with the belt?
Tell me, please, we are arrested.
Why are you so sultry with that?
I'm like, why?
Emma, help me.
I can't be I guess we can't be together now Juna It's so
dangerous People are watching us Yeah We're just too sultry
And deep voice And oh my god We're gonna kiss And everything
That's crazy Yeah People are just watching us Like oh my
gosh Are you going to do something on stage Like oh my god I
think we need an after hour Are you?
I think we need an after hour segment here For these days Oh
my god Oh congratulations On winning this To match Emma you
deserve some breakfast oh my gosh i guess i am the final
dungeon boss can't wait to meet my final opponent whoever
you are get ready i mean you might after this your next
opponent could be either nana snuffy or fuyo unfortunately
snuffy is still a little mi so we're gonna move on to
bracket two until she appears okay okay okay oh no oh shit
so we'll we'll make sure we'll make sure uh when she's back
we will commence go back to the match with her and we'll uh
so yeah anyway i realized we're doing this live because i
realized i forgot to download haka's wrestler so oh my god
oh no i had everybody but haka i apologize haka like i said
like this is the first time i organized wrestle tuber guys
this is the very first wrestle tuber 2024 um so of course
there's gonna be a scuff along the way and if i forget to
download haka it just just had to be the issue right now is
i'm trying to find haka right now Oh my god.
They're so many.
Fill some dead air.
It's like, we can talk about Dungeons more.
There's so many wrestlers.
There's like 10 pages.
Oh, I found him.
There's 10 pages of wrestlers.
Oh, wait.
Am I next?
No, you're not.
Oh, wait.
I'm just making the...
All right.
Because we might as well roll in.
Bracket number two, which is Anon and Nia.
for bracket number two my baby girls that's my girls freeze
them for those who want to see the bracket two this is going
to be bracket two guys Sayu unfortunately like I said Sayu's
going to be on day two because there was some delays and so
he won't be here for day one so Luto and Sayu's match will
be moved to day two everybody so can we drag Anon and Nia to
the year goodbye Emma Goodbye.
Bye-bye.
See you guys again later.
Thank you ladies.
Nah, Nia.
Hi.
Hello.
I've been seeing the beef on Twitter.
You're not, sorry, you're not on the screen yet.
Oh, we're not there yet.
You're not there yet.
There's you.
It's just a head.
Okay, you're tiny here.
It's an actual head.
Whoa.
Why is it just a head?
How did he go?
How did the rest of me?
Sorry, tight accurate.
There we go.
That's tight accurate.
The more you complain, the timier you get.
No, no, no.
Okay, okay, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
That's right.
She's becoming chat.
No, it's okay.
She knows her place now.
Well, to start off, I've been watching the beef between you
guys on Twitter.com, and I'm unsure whether this is a brawl
or, like, something else.
Wait, what do you mean by that?
None wants to get choked, and...
I didn't know how to respond to that.
This is the perfect place for that.
true that's true yeah but she said please choke me mommy so
no matter what happens i lose like she wins either way but
you're not into that like maybe you wouldn't choke your
beloved bunny yeah you hate her you hate her you hate me
don't you hate me please oh wait wait i don't know what
answer is i don't know what is the right answer to be so
angry at me i don't want you to have the satisfaction no
i'll blue blue ball you i'll blue ball you whoa that's
fucked up whoa okay you know what maybe she deserves it i'm
scared is this wrestling i don't know i feel like i feel
like there's something else i think her back on the back on
the casting couch again.
I feel like this is the casting couch now.
Well.
I feel like there's some, like, very strange tension in the
air.
Like, I don't know if it's a sexual or I'm unsure now.
I don't know what to say.
You did this, Junio.
I did this.
I asked him a question.
I was like, please, I want to get I want to get choked.
Are you, like, perpetuated, like, More...
Sultry environment.
No!
It's my voice.
Your sexy presence.
Oh my...
Oh my fucking god.
Gina, I'm also open for you to choke me too.
I'm not gonna choke you.
So what are you gonna do in order to beat Nia?
I'm going to lay there.
Okay.
I don't think...
I think you'll lose if you just lay...
If you're not moving for like X amount of seconds, will just
lose so how would that work you know it's like maybe i can
inflict passion into her passion we love the passion in the
ring yeah that's true true wrestling passion right yeah yeah
yeah exactly exactly yeah that's the passion we're looking
for wow i i don't know i feel i don't Non, I don't want to
really wish you luck, but I hope you do well.
We're not supposed to be biased, Juno.
You're part of the broadcast staff.
Wait, no, I need all the support you can get.
I'm biased.
Look, you got this, girlies.
Please win.
Beat each other up and choke each other.
Yeah!
All right, off we go, ladies.
We're going to take that to the ring, that passion that we
saw here.
Yeah, passion!
Back to the castle table, we go.
Goodbye, forever.
Goodbye, guys.
Goodbye, good luck.
Good luck, good luck.
We believe in you.
Wow.
I just put on a pull, and it seems like people really want
Adon to win.
It's the choking buff, you know.
It's the choking.
Do you speak from experience?
No, no.
Why do you know so much wait but why do you know so much
about the choking buff I just believe that you know I think
anybody who is a masochist and is in wrestling they
experience the pain and it gives them a buff that I know
from experience oh okay oh what the hell is that oh my god
you know the one type of wrestler that wants to be choked.
The following contest is scheduled for one fall.
Introducing first.
Oh my god.
Look at her ass.
Naya!
Naruto Itachi outfits.
Yeah.
I like how the background is like an Easter feeling yeah we
can have like a view from the back too i don't think there's
a view everywhere oh my gosh she has a rose she has several
roses with her yeah she's so elegant oh that's a word pose
for us girl pose she's so what you don't think she's
beautiful i'm feeling i'm I'm feeling like Easter morning
right now.
Oh my God, it's true.
It's Easter, guys.
Jesus has died for our sins, and he's getting ready to be
resurrected into that thing.
Yeah.
That's what you're going to see on Sunday.
Oh, boy.
Apologies, the last one was add-on.
I'm sorry, I got the wrong card.
Introducing their opponents.
Who's the opponent, sir?
Who is it?
Who's that?
The real Naya!
Woohoo!
Wait, they're both furries.
Look, they have like, yeah.
Whoa!
She's so cool.
She means business.
Oh my, she lost a tooth.
She lost a tooth.
Luckily, veneers are in right now.
Oh my god.
Look at her go she's out there getting those tax forms done
I hope everything's all taken care of you know everything's
signed properly yeah tax fraud is not a joke and she's here
to prove it damn whoa oh my god some ladies just got
pregnant just now.
Oh, was it you?
No,
it was Gerard.
Gerard's out there in the stands right now going Nia!
Please, I'm already dead.
Please.
I can hear him now hearing him chat out.
Nia!
Yeah, I think I just heard him say it.
Yeah, come on, Gerard.
Say it again!
Nia!
Please, the match is already over.
Could you please just watch the different wrestlers, please?
Wow!
Oh my god!
The kick from Nia right off the fucking bat.
I'm loving Nia's like Dorothy outfit right now.
Oh yeah, she...
We're not in Kansas anyway.
Following the yellow brick road.
Which is...
Bro, what the...
What is she doing?
is choking her wait a minute wait wait here's the wrong
person getting choked yeah you're supposed to get choked
aton wait anna has like a fanny pack did you see that yeah
she has wait is it yes no way no she oh my god it's on the
bridge she stole limo's moon i see london i see france i see
nia's underpass no see look there's the fanny pack to the
right I do see it, yeah.
Oh my god, what do you have in there?
Yeah, what is she hiding in there?
Yeah, Anon.
What do you have?
What do you call this movement?
That's the queen's wave.
I don't know why everything's British thee.
Oh my god, is that...
Move over, King Charles.
Queen Nia is here to take that throne.
To be fair, it won't be that hard to do.
He's very old.
Oh, yeah.
I just realized she, Anon has a tattoo of her own face.
Anon has a lot going on.
I think it's, you know.
But what is she doing?
Anon, please.
Get up.
She's showing off.
Oh, what the hell was it?
What a miss.
Oh, you okay?
I think both of these guys need glasses.
What's going on here?
They definitely did not put on the contacts, Mint.
No, not at all.
Oh, what a slam!
Another slam!
And a kick to...
They really like kicking each other's backs.
Alright, come on, you can choke her.
Yeah, this is choking moment.
Peak choke moment!
I call this walking the dog.
.
clip it check clip it she barked for free on my own channel
i see the views going up right now we'll do anything for the
views for free oh another stop on the face yeah nia's just
not giving her the satisfaction of the choke She ended up
choking her instead.
Oh!
A person in!
Okay, her face looks like the Grinch for like one second.
Did you know?
But her heart is not growing three sizes.
Oh, it's definitely not the heart.
No.
It does not lead.
No worry.
What she's wearing right now does not need any imagination.
Mm-mm.
you know what i noticed i noticed nia is like a fusion
between like her dog and like dorothy and her dog with a
fucking r i don't know i don't know anyone who gets cocky is
gonna yeah is he gonna oh wait not punished is she actually
not gonna get punishment they're at five though oh my god oh
my god oh my god she like better ladies please this is not
the bedroom ladies i feel bad for the janitor that's true
imagine i have to clean all that like all the sweaty bodies
too when chad could just do it for free well chad you want
to get hired today it's a volunteer job though it's a
volunteer job chat yeah what non-one because she was out of
the ring the fight and support what the fuck is she doing
what does she do here is your winner by count out it's canon
annum oh my god nia nia did not know what happened what
happened nia the ring was right there i mean i feel like it
was big enough right like like it was there the lackluster
of a Her face is on her nose.
Did you see that?
Oh, that's what that is.
Yeah, that's her face on the nose.
I'm loving this dream work space we've got going on here.
Very, you know what?
That's true.
We got the B movie right here.
B movie at home.
This is the whole B.
That's the whole B.
Let's talk to the ladies and see what they think.
Let's talk.
Hit me away from this woman Hit me away from her You should
hit me harder, Nia It wasn't enough for me Look at her Wow,
is I gonna beat that thing Literally She's out to seek
Tougher matches Someone who will just Cause her pain Nia in
her defense she did explain what she was gonna do in that
match and she did lay for most of the time so i don't know
how you didn't beat her ass i don't know how i didn't win
you're gonna hit me a bit harder you know i wasn't feeling
it she like to be fair she literally like waited for you to
get back to the ring to hit her again so like that's just
embarrassing i have bad stamina all right
me out so how how long were you prepping for this tournament
though i would assume like at least two weeks yeah you know
i there was no catnip involved at all i wasn't just oh
you're not clean it's she already you're not clean no no no
i am i am whoa you're not oh my god i took my my test i i'm
qualified okay you okay all right i mean doesn't really
matter she's already eliminated been some B grade cat nip
right there.
I don't know where your dealer was.
Yeah, you might want to find someone else.
Yeah, you might, you know, I hear, you know, I know
somebody, you know, and yeah, I know somebody, and she's
like, maybe right here in this room, and I know she has a
lot of cat nip, right, mint.
Why me?
You have a cat!
Oh, you're right.
I have two.
Have you ever chatted them?
No, I do.
Come to me.
Come to me now.
I'll hook you up.
Thank you.
Hold on.
Did you...
I forgot I was going to fight.
I can't make it sound weird.
No, no, no.
Did you...
Were you satisfied after this match, or are you longing for
more?
I'm longing for more, mommy.
You're longing for more.
Whoa.
Ladies.
Now I'm wondering if it was...
a mistake to have you as an interview.
No!
Listen, listen, I am...
Well, non-congratulations.
I'm assuming that each tattoo you have on your body is each
win that you have obtained in your career.
So where will your next tattoo go?
Oh, that's where I want them to hit me.
I'll put more on my body.
You know?
You know where?
my neck oh i was actually have like hand tattoos on my neck
too to like you know show that where to choke me i see i see
oh you know you make it to day two you can easily edit you
know you could add that tattoo before day two comes on call
up your tattoo parlor and add that i'll call him right now
that's some good confidence yes we won i mean if you make it
to day two add on Alright.
Okay, I'll try my best.
Whose dog was that?
Oh, my bad.
Sorry.
I thought I was you, Doki.
Alright, guys, it's off to the next matchup with Juna and
Haka.
Is Haka actually here though?
Like, is he?
So, okay.
I am I...
Wait, Haka's online.
I see Haka.
He's here, but he's not really here.
He told me.
He's taking a shit.
Okay, well...
Oh!
I'm sorry, Haka!
All right.
Wow, exposing Haka off the bat.
Okay.
Hey, Haka, we got some TMI distance.
Is this from the bathroom?
Yeah, are you like in the bathroom, Haka?
Like, what the fuck?
No, I literally just got out, okay?
I literally...
You just got out.
Like, what's going on?
Sorry, can you repeat that?
My ears can't register, like, such a high-pitched voice.
voice what are you talking about what the fuck is he hype
his voice hello oh it's so high oh my god bro i the the
wavelengths bro i can't oh you're so short too holy shit
damn i literally told you hold up i'm taking a shit and then
i took a shit and i was like okay ping me was it a nervous
shit is that why you had a shit oh yeah absolutely you know
when you were in a you know in a wrestling competition with
you know fighting a fucking eel you kind of have to like you
know he have the tank yeah why because like you're gonna be
over you got be fucking over when i'm done with you did you
wash your hands by the way the gilding just got out like
give me a sec i need to move i watched i watched my hands
like fucking like medical style and i like off to the
fucking elbow yeah i don't even mean you should have you
should have kept them dirty grossed her out a little no
because i i don't want to give her like you know like like
poison damage over time from your stinky breath punching
over here yeah wait i thought like birds eat eels he's a
tiny bird yeah okay okay he's figuring he is pretty tiny my
my tail is as tall as him you have to understand sorry this
is the accurate height i'm sorry this is the acula yeah
sigh yeah
Who the fuck?
Who the fuck mirrored me in the announcement?
Why am I mirrored?
Why is my hair the other side?
Why am I Aka?
Look, it's all it has to match.
Yeah.
Really look at that and I was just like, whoa.
That's not me.
Yeah, I'm scared.
I hope we have a good fight.
I don't know if I'll win, but I'll try my best.
It has to be a fair fight.
you know we have to we have to abide by the rules of nature
the rules oh you're right predator versus predator yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah what's the rules of nature wait but
you're both predators survival the fittest survival the
fittest who's gonna win me um i'm kidding i'm kidding wait
you don't want to win of dinosaurs but we saw what happened
to the did you already show them my gladiator you show them
my gladiator what's the gladiator bro my fighter is built as
It's you short though?
Is he like a short snack?
No, no, no, man.
He's fucking huge.
It's huge.
It doesn't really matter to Haka.
Haka, what do you mean?
He, it's you.
Well, you see, I like you also bring a whop in.
Oh.
Wow.
Well, you see, when you're a performer, you kind of have to
find, you know, different options.
and that that guy just looked at me funny and I was just
like hey you want to make 20 bucks already admitting to
fraud you should be confessing after the match so when you
lose you can be like that wasn't me anymore no no no no I'm
honest I'm honest that's that's you know that's a cool thing
about being an idol you have to be honest yeah you know as
honest as I am that I took a shit
you do in the in the in the match aka let's see if the the
guy you paid off is it just like the guy you don't worry
he's gonna fucking destroy everyone he's gonna destroy oh my
god I believe in you you got this all right let's get off to
the game we're gonna head of the casters broadcast we see
you guys in the ring we'll see you and the homeless guy in
the ring no I don't Oh, don't say that!
Alright.
Also, Mint, can you turn up yourself a little bit more?
The sound guy's saying he wants to hear you more.
Oh, okay.
Hello.
That was enough.
I don't know.
My ears don't work as good.
Me neither.
Alright.
It seems...
Oh my god.
A lot of people think Hakka's gonna win.
It's because he's not him.
I mean, like, he's pretty short, right?
He has those heels on.
Let me see.
Yeah, I mean, we'll see again.
It doesn't matter the size.
It matters kind of the agility like I like how he's like 2d
here like Wait, why is Haka just What Why is he just
himself?
Okay What the fuck is so short?
Oh my god Oh, but it doesn't matter It doesn't fucking
matter.
He does not need height No, exactly.
The taller they are, the harder they fall.
Exactly.
I mean, I don't think these, I don't think any of these
wrestlers are them.
Like, I think they both hired some.
I don't know.
I can't see the resemblance with Juno.
Who?
Like, how, like the furry tail?
It feels like Juno just...
The furry tail?
Juno gave like this random guy like $5 at Walmart to go
crazy.
I don't know.
budget the budget cosplay oh guys i just realized we didn't
do the intro guys we were so sorry we got distracted by 2d
haka all right should we you know i mean it's still early we
can restart it we don't know who's gonna win yeah true true
yeah we don't know who's gonna win so we can restart this
guys stop fighting guys guys this is not scripted they were
they were yeah we told them up.
Why is he 2D?
I don't know.
Something made him 2D.
I got distracted because you didn't even realize that he was
2D.
I didn't either.
Yeah, just looking at him.
Just a standing man emoji there.
Haka, Haka, you were not winning.
Yeah, it's true.
You were absolutely not winning, Haka.
Here we go.
The following contest is scheduled for one fall.
First!
I like how his friendly e-lady.
A bit dodgy!
That Judah Unagi!
The friendly e-lady!
Oh my, what?
I don't know, anything long and slippery.
I've seen those.
They're not very friendly.
Riverdale shit, like the cab thing.
Yeah.
What do you mean Riverdale?
Like, do you not see that fucking close-up?
And he's like, ah.
Yeah, it was like a little fan service, you know?
Yeah, a little bit of...
I mean, to be fair, she was giving the silky... This is the
slowest walk.
Please, can we pick it up?
What are you doing?
We have a scheduler!
Maybe we should have skipped the intros.
Why are you looking at the camera again?
She was just like, my eyes are here, ladies.
Yeah.
Wait, did you hear that, that lady of the audience, like,
yeah!
Wow, Juno, you're such your biggest fan over there!
Yeah!
Yes, girl, give us nothing!
That's how we like it!
Woo!
We have no standards!
Let's go!
Yeah, finally, a little bit of pizzazz.
Whoa!
Finally!
I can like imagine you to just be like, And introducing
their opponent, Hailing from the bathroom where they just
took an enormous shit!
Oh!
Waka, Waka, Benzo and Haka!
Whoa!
At least Haka's giving us something.
Something.
Oh my god.
He's wearing a mask too.
Yeah.
Keep it on.
Ladies, he leaves all of that on.
Yeah.
All right.
The crowd, I can't tell where the crowd is supporting right
now, you know.
I like how his intro was like, like one third of Gina's
intro.
I know.
That was so...
Oh my god.
All right.
Finally, we're back in it.
Oh, another throw from Hakka.
What does the back of Juna's shirt say?
Family.
Just so all you guys know, the ones that had, like,
fan-created wrestlers, the talents themselves chose the
wrestler.
So she specifically chose.
this guy that she paid off in the street.
Okay, okay, okay.
With family.
There's no family here.
I mean, Hakka's still, Hakka's winning still.
I like how he's wrestling in flip-flops, though.
Oh, damn, you're right.
Yeah.
This guy's ready to go to the beach.
Oh, the kick to the head.
What do you call that, Mint?
What do you call this move?
That was the screwy McDewey.
The screwy McDewey?
live in WrestleTuber I thought that was a myth mint.
Nope.
It was real and you know Haka is really proving himself.
What is what is what is what?
I call that the Humpty Dumpty.
So no.
He did have a great fall.
He's swinging that she's swinging that leg out hoping that
Humpty Dumpty can be pieced back together again how did you
miss juna's huge how that's true haka put on your glasses
haka get back in the ring guys you don't want to get
eliminated like mia yeah oh and the dick if she had one i
don't think wait i think that was the stomach oh you mean
the dick is not there
it i guess oh nice at least she put him back in the ring she
could she should have left him outside the ring though they
could have easily you know won by the default yeah but no
this is a fair there hanka said he wanted a fair game so
that's true back outside the ring whoa cutscene oh yeah
these people right here are getting a good show yeah he's
hyping the crowd up.
He's like, do you like what you see?
They're like, yeah, Hakka's toes!
They're out, they're out!
For free!
They're not censored, guys!
Four?
Alright, come on, jump on!
Yeah!
Oh!
Oh my god.
She's definitely gonna need a doctor tomorrow.
Yeah.
I wonder if Lymo's chiropractic service This is open.
I mean, she's eliminated, so it should be open by now.
Yeah.
She needs one, too.
She needs the money, guys.
Wait, what number are they at?
Four.
Four!
Juna, get up, Juna!
Get up, Juna!
Oh, no!
I like how Juna was, like, indecisive there.
She's like, do I pick him up, or do I, like, push him?
Oh, my God.
Two!
To the audience?
Whoa!
The audience is definitely getting their tickets worth.
Yeah.
This is, this was, but it's free for everybody watching at
home.
Yeah, it's free for you guys.
No pay-per-view.
Yeah.
Right here on Doki Bird Network.
What the fuck was that?
The BDN.
The T.
I mean, D.
Wait.
I think you're missing an S there a little dyslexic a little
okay wait one two oh Haka got it out Haka you were winning
how did you fucking get pinned already oh my god she's
measuring the cranium again okay oh it's choking the elbow
to the stomach and the kick Oh my god.
Oh my god.
She's like, I'm a star baby, too.
This is the this is the pay me like your French lady The
infamous pay me like the French lady.
I thought that move was reserved for only Leo I thought it
was banned Are all these moves apparently banned?
Oh god, Hakka's Hakka's making a beat right now.
He's using this beat for his new song.
Wow Oh another one one two three
and here is your winner oh waka waka benzo and haka oh juna
better stick to interviewing yeah juna i don't think
wrestling was for you man bro he was like he was like making
a beat and everything too you saw that yeah he was really
revving up the crowd all right let's go to the interview to
talk to yeah uh to talk to the loser and the winner oh she's
already there she has to be there all right i'll see you
there all right i don't get paid enough i don't get paid
enough what can i say i fucking warned you i'm sorry
juna how could you lose you literally watch like so many
games oh sorry um the the guy that i paid um is useless and
worthless and uh uh-huh mm-hmm that sounds like a lot of
excuses well i'm gonna need some other criticism besides
just from a lot of excuses i need like actual criticism doki
you've been using that one a lot doki how do you feel
winning against uh juna there it feels great you know the
the blood of my fucking enemies my hand it feels great
you're gonna have to wash him again you know what you don't
fucking know is that i'm a medium you know i possess him i
possess his fucking ass oh yeah i thought you my medium like
medium size i was so no that's good that's who you know i'm
after all medium is premium you know but yeah i possess his
fucking ass and i i beat the shit out of you bro i'll be
able to i i I don't know if I should feel honored, but it
was an experience.
I can't believe I got beat by a twink.
You know, that's crazy.
It only happens like once in your life.
I like how you say that you threw so you had that honor to
say that you were beat by a twink.
I like how Hakka was just speechless.
He didn't even know what to say to that.
Hakka, do you need like five minutes to think of like a
comeback?
are you gonna go i'm like i am sitting down here realizing
what you just said i'm just like trying to think of like wow
this is my life after all you know i could have been i could
have been more than this swimming lessons too if you really
need them because i remember that story your swimming story
hey bro shut the up what is it what is the story yeah yeah
share with the class yeah share with the class guys i got
chased by a fucking crab and i almost drowned what the what
you got
literally chaser that it was ground wow maybe you shouldn't
have shared that story in the class maybe i shouldn't have
shared that story huh i like how they're still trash talking
even though juna lost but i feel like it's banter you know
at the end of the day juna might have lost the battle yeah
but she won the war let me tell you that the mental war the
mental war well thank you again haka and juna for that
exciting match we are going to do a small intermission here
because it's time for mint to be rotated well me and mint to
be rotated out in the casting table so we're gonna have a
set of new casters joining in for half of bracket two and
bracket three thank you guys for joining us for the first uh
for the first half thank you for having us yeah thank you
guys thank you for joining thank you sir sleigh all right
we're gonna be going to intermission now we'll see you guys
in five to ten minutes bye bye thank you for losing good out
bye bye bye bye guys
Hello, everybody, and welcome back to WrestleTuber.
I will be stepping out, I'll be rotated out as a caster, and
I'll be taking a little break now.
But, as we know, we have several casters for WrestleTuber,
and they will be taking over for me and Mint.
So, why don't we welcome Gerard and Octavio?
Hello!
Okay, this is awkward.
Oh my god.
Get rotated.
Hey!
Hello, everybody.
Hi.
Why are you so mellow?
I...
I don't want to show my face on screen anymore for a bit.
I just fucking lost.
Oh, right.
And I don't want to be here anymore.
The newly fossilized dinosaur.
I thought I'd be gloating all over the place, but no!
I'm just...
God damn it.
Hello, guys.
Hello, everybody.
My name is Gerard T.
Rexford, and I am Hall of Stars.
English is devilishly handsome bounty hunter and the leader
of the armistice unit and today I am joined by my co-host
over here I am the opulent of the tonic a piratic puppeteer
from bounty hunting armistice horse horse English my name is
Octavio hello hello hello we practice an intro let's do it
yeah yeah we totally did not yeah hello Minasan welcome
we're already fumbling don't get this was not part of the
plan why do you throw us in here now we don't guys here's
the bracket this is this is like a very very big dream come
true to join um wwe because this has been also a part of my
childhood and uh yeah thank you thank you very much doki for
um letting us participate in this match even though i
fucking lost you know it's still a great opportunity to like
uh be able to participate in a massive event such as this so
thank you thank you thank you this is better than the wwe
because it's vtubers yeah it's a bunch of weirdos and i
never thought i'd be joining in an actual match you know
technically this counts you know like uh that was your last
match it's not in yeah it was my last it's not an actual
television but hey it's youtube everybody it's technically
television at the same time i'd like to say hi to my mom and
friends out there oh my god they're all dead y'all yeah
they're dead 65 million years ago no no no no don't remind
me but anyway let's look at the bracket shall we let's look
at the bracket okay okay so we just finished with a matchup
of um uh uh juna unagi and banzo in haka our senpai yeah
congratulations to banzo in haka for actually winning that
one It was totally unexpected because according to Octavio,
like right before we even went to here, he didn't even
believe in his senpai.
He said, oh my God, I didn't even think Haka would pass
because Hall of Stars are fucking weak.
And you got that fucking ball.
Bro, you have to move for us.
The only one I believe in is myself and no one else.
Everybody dunk on him if he fucking loses, all right?
Congratulations, Haka, you cheater.
You cheated in some way.
But hey, Hall of Stars represent, they won.
Congratulations, though, to the remaining participants who
actually won.
So thank you.
And now up next is Philean and Remilia.
They are going to be scheduled for the next match.
So are you guys ready to rumble?
I think they are.
Let's wait.
They need to respond via chat.
They need to match my energy.
Match my energy.
to rumble yeah come on what am i supposed to say i am ready
to rumble yes we are ready so let us now proceed to the one
v1 interview section yoink hello wait um hey guys i mean i'm
really sorry i was chilling in the interview while we wait
sorry let me move out real quick guys oh my god we're
walking we're walking currently walking towards the
interview room there we go there we go okay we finally
moving out oh i had to use my legs to get all right all
right okay so let us bring in the people peeps show
yourselves and We'll introduce ourselves.
Why am I just a PNG?
We're all PNGs, except the casters, please.
VTubers, what the fuck do you want?
We have two forms, PNGs and live 2D.
Hey, this looks nice.
This WWE tournament is very nice.
Don't you dare dis on it.
It's very nice.
It's very well produced.
Who do you think you are?
You're fully animated?
You got the effing budget behind you?
What is this, man?
I have casting perms, all right?
You are PNGs.
You're literally just about to fight.
unless oh wait you are yeah yeah oh no okay what are we
doing what are we doing what are we doing oh i'm so sorry
you and remilia so how are you guys feeling i'm ready to
smash her face into the floor and then deliver like amazon
prime straight back to i don't know where she lives but
she's going there oh well rame what's your response to that
what's your response hey i know i know i come a tiny size
but breaking your kneecaps is my floor case listen listen
i've got power of darkness and light on my side lakes faster
than speed i know i'm vertically challenged but i'm standing
tall than you right now in this oh you think it's so tall
how tall are you how tall are you i'm 139 everybody i'm 139
that's tall speaking magic i'm tall suddenly oh my god
they're clipping through the set oh no are you okay wait you
look flat as frick uh What's going on in your chest?
Low blow!
The match hasn't even started yet.
It only hurts.
I made me flat!
Okay, but my butt is packing.
What about you?
What do you bring in the picture?
I bring in a Mastermind IQ.
I made business tycoon.
It's like an elementary school fight right here.
I'm totally dead.
I am a CEO of a business.
Oh, you got a boob on your nose.
Ooh, you got a poopy on your butt.
Okay.
Yeah.
elementary style fighting Jesus Christ so who do you guys
think is gonna win today's match well I I can I hear their
war cries I'll do it give me a roar can I please hear a war
cry from both of you guys let me go first whoa okay okay
that was strangely adorable that's like a solid eight out of
ten I'm so scared dating holy i was channeling your inner
senzawa var exe nuzzle passes on you oh you so warm i'll
show you i'm getting attacked oh brain damage oh oh oh not
the psychic damage god i uh i thought i'm stupid but i guess
god made you an exception oh okay oh she called you stupid
oh oh oh oh Yeah, yeah.
Well, the pod called the kettle black dog.
I mean, look at you.
You're effing stupid.
You're short.
You're flat.
We're the same person Um, guys, what do you say to me?
It's true.
It's like a gym fighting itself.
I think this is personal now.
Are we doing it more than your flatness?
Bro, stop projection, bro.
Stop it now.
What are you asking?
Twitter user?
What the frick?
Are you fighting for real?
I am.
Oh, for real?
All right, let's go.
Let's go.
WWE stuff, drop the Addy.
Well, it seems like they're ready to fight, so...
Okay.
Let's take it to the ring.
Because we are going to transition to the actual match now.
Do I get to get to know why I beat her up?
Don't get me.
I'm sorry.
There we go.
Sorry, that's my lunch break.
Sorry, I didn't realize you guys didn't even be here, too.
The melee.
Wait.
You just keep calling.
Sorry, I was just chilling here.
Need to go backstage.
I didn't realize you guys are going to be here too.
Like, what was I supposed to know that?
Guys, okay, give me a sec.
Go to the break room.
Hey, what?
This, there is no break room.
Did you not see what Neuro and Zantreya did to that break
room?
Let me in!
Let me inside!
We're knocking on this door.
Let us in.
Give me a sec, guys.
I just realized.
Let me get it!
Guys, be fucking patient, guys!
Oh my god!
Hello!
You told us to cast!
Be patient!
I realized I didn't find the key to the...
I need to find the key, guys!
It's so bad, guys!
Give me a sec, I'm trying to find the key!
Give me a sec!
What is taking so long?
Guys!
What is happening?
I forgot.
I forgot where the key is!
all right security security oh you're this is why we have
day two guys i bet you actually prepared it you're still
you're still setting it up so that's what's taking so long
jesus christ this is why we have day two don't worry guys
the day two will be even better day two everything you can
tell i'm doing this all by myself doing great so far guys
i'm just trying to find gerard right now there he is there
you go okay there i am i like it there you go there here you
are all right we're in baby we got it
finally finally we can see the matchup between billion and
remilia
bro look at their look at their models here the wrestlers.
What is that?
Billion reminds me of a feral ghoul in Fallout.
On Ramilia's hair.
What is that supposed to be?
White meat.
Looks like an elephant.
The following contest.
One in a billion.
Billion.
We got kicked out.
Uh-oh, we got kicked out.
He disappeared from existence.
Help!
Help, let us in, okay.
Let us in!
We can't commentate!
Oh no!
Let us in!
Okay, okay, we're- Let's go!
Oh, Jesus.
Oh, that's cute, though.
That's cute.
Very- Let's go, Philly and Filipino boy!
I don't know why they call Philly in that way.
Damn, she's dancing.
That is some heavy moves right there.
Do you think that will pack a punch when it comes?
comes to the ring though i don't know if you ask me they
will better need the moves the moves yeah the moves philly
in here a true turp scorpion just showing it off bam wow
total confidence what the hell what the hell what oh my god
what we have a performer here everybody is this a dance
battle what's going on here introducing their opponent oh
shit someone's in canada hailing from canada the smallest
yet greatest idea
look at that oh the flag of canada behind oh oh with that
outfit It's like a maid outfit.
Well, she's made for this.
Look at that swagger.
Do we have a poll in the chat?
Who do you think will win?
She's the most swaggy angel I've ever seen.
Phelian Oremilia.
Bruh.
Wait, what?
I'm looking at two screens right now.
Here we go.
I like the color scheme here.
Yeah, very elegant moves though.
Reminds me of the good old Canada.
Oh Canada oh Canada.
Why are they all doing dance moves?
Did they plan this out?
It's like they're doing dance moves.
Why are they doing this?
Yeah, yeah, this is gonna be a dance battle right here.
Battle of the dance.
I will be super disappointed if it isn't like dance moves
that they're like a swinging at each other.
Ooh.
Hey yo, hey yo, hey yo.
Whoa.
That's flexibility.
Damn, damn, damn.
got rubber bands for arms and legs just showing off that
flexibility to the crowd showing that they are not meant to
be grinding as well what the heck oh wow i'll give in that
oh and it doesn't end there it just keeps going it just
keeps going oh finally the match is starting it's just they
have to like um perform like uh they're on like on stage
performers in a sense they're technically This is real.
They're not fake.
This is a real fight.
And the matchup begins.
Oh my God.
Immediately.
With a running attack.
And with a counter right there, bouncing off.
And got caught.
And an attack.
Oh, I thought that was going to be a combo.
And they're doing a six twist.
He's so aggressive already at the start.
An arm bar, everybody.
And the submission.
Out of the way.
Oh, kick to the leg.
Oh, oh, that hurts.
Look at those combos, man.
Oh, come to the corner.
A close line!
Yes!
It's the only move I know!
One!
Two!
Oh, no, no, no.
Still too early.
Too early, too early.
But, you know, that would be funny, though, if they actually
got a pin!
Whoa!
Reversal!
They're taking turns here.
Ah!
Focusing on the hands.
Gonna injure that hand.
And me to the face that's got a gotta say that's pretty
smart move actually like aiming for the arms because they
can't actually yeah aim for the limbs nor punch anyone else
if they actually damage true true yeah they can grab the
rope when you pin them too oh a flying attack and a ddt oh
it wasn't a ddt i thought it was a d it was an elbow it was
an elbow the subverted expectations oh a kick oh is that
allowed what's going on oh whoa everyone's doing some flashy
moves and everybody's like somersaulting one one two oh i
thought that was already it that was early but a two count
this early damn and he escaped oh trying to run away from
the responsibilities huh oh reversal let's see if you can
fly away with this one with those wings of yours and
carrying Oh, someone's bleeding!
That drew some blood!
We got first blood!
First blood!
Philean is bleeding from the nose!
Oh!
One of those things again.
The complicated, simplistic thing.
Remilia and Philean fight is already intense.
There's already blood gushing out through the ring, and are
they gonna get counted out?
Five seconds!
They have additional five seconds until...
If you kick an angel like that...
One gets decided to be the victor.
Throw inside the ring.
Oh, what's gonna happen?
Reversal please?
Oh, it wasn't a finisher.
That's it, it's a pin!
What a flashy pin!
Ah, that was quick!
Too quick!
Throwing it.
And another one!
Could you please stop hitting me on the neck?
Damn, look at these flashy ass moves!
Oh, it's a submission!
It's a submission!
Damn, but it was able to grapple free.
I mean, get free.
I've only been seeing like a big bodied men fighting, but
I've never seen like a these builds before, fight.
Correct me if I'm wrong, but I think there's the first like
a very fast-paced kind of movement like a fight.
Yeah, yeah, we got thin representation from Philean right
now.
Everybody's big, bulky and muscly.
Oh, shit, that's gotta hurt.
Hey.
Oh, reversal.
Throw him.
Drop kick.
What is going to happen?
Come on, come on.
Ah, Somersault, kick to the face!
Oh my god, that works!
That might be it!
Oh no!
She's waiting for the finisher!
The default finisher!
Default finisher!
Yeah!
And here it is!
Ah!
That's the finisher right there!
Kick to the face!
Are they down for the count?
Is this set for Philly?
One!
Are they gonna win?
Two!
Ah!
Kick to the what?
Hey, yo!
Fucking double!
That's fire!
Let's go!
Another pin!
Oh, they're pinned!
It's maybe it!
Two!
Oh!
Fighting back!
She's so strong!
Hang in there!
Escape the wall!
Oh, you missed!
Oh, that's pretty embarrassing.
I don't think that's...
Unfortunately.
Sponsored by Gamer Subs, everybody.
Ah!
Oh!
Pin!
Reversal!
Very aggressive with those pins.
Let's go!
Two!
Oh!
Phyllian is actually stronger than she looks.
as a dancer her limbs are very limber two finishers isn't
enough to bring one down this is a very fast paced battle it
is it's like watching an anime fight oh oh here we go again
oh crap what is that athleticism flexibility on display that
was something it was nice very nice Amelia escaping through
the turnbuckles throwing him again what is the second Oh,
this is crazy.
How can one person have such athleticism and agility?
Everyone here is a high flyer and a pin.
A pin.
Here it is.
Is this a finisher?
Is this it?
One, two, three.
Oh, there's nothing.
They counted out.
Oh, this is still anybody's game.
Anybody.
Oh, another finisher.
Another finisher.
Finisher.
Wait for that finisher.
Oh, you missed.
They missed.
What?
Excuse me.
Okay.
A body slam.
I'm having trouble breathing.
That's a body slam.
Okay.
Wait, let me mute.
He is about...
Gerard, my co-caster is about to die, apparently.
Oh, hi, flyer, Amelia.
There's so much energy going on.
I can't help it.
Breathe, breathe.
I'm breathing, I'm breathing.
Oh shit, is this it?
If you don't breathe, Gerard, I'm going to pin you down.
Oh, that's the same finisher that I got wiped.
Oh shit, oh shit.
Oh, hit to the back.
Kind of disrespectful.
You could have pinned him already, but no, you had to do it
outside.
The disrespect is immense.
Could we please just end this?
Oh, someone's...
Wee!
The angel flew around Billy in there.
The disrespect, put an end to it, please.
they're still fighting inside no outside they have to get
inside or else come on what's gonna be disqualified five
it's five seconds oh shit is this it six remilia's knocked
out you have to knock him out stun him stun him and that's
it yeah one more time why'd you bring it no come on that was
that was a missed opportunity but that's a pin though it's a
pin it could work might work one
Here is your winner.
One in a billion.
Billion.
That was fucking intense.
Everyone was like flying.
They were like throwing punches, like throwing kicks.
Everyone was throwing each other at whatever.
That was fucking fun.
Holy crap.
We got that massive flex.
We got high flyers.
Mm-hmm.
And that match is a rating out.
was great four out of five amazing amazing thank you
everybody so much rated four out of five stars
okay here we are at the interviewer's table how does it feel
oh hello oh how does it feel to beat the child why do you
guys phrase it like that Listen, okay, if Stephens are a
hell of a drug, I'm not trying to say anything, but it was
easier than it looked.
I'm not going to lie.
Oh, wow.
I mean, looking at the matches, it seemed very close.
I don't know.
Well, you know, I like to put on a good show at the end of
the day.
You know, it's a little bit about giving them a bit of a
chance.
The content.
I get it.
This makes sense.
Yeah, yeah.
I was sent back on the start so I could come back on the
ninth.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah, I get it.
Hold on.
Yeah, so, Wemi.
Are you okay?
The...
The devil may cry, but I cry harder.
No!
You made her cry, Billion!
Chat, why is she like this?
I can't... It's all your fault.
I can't...
You made this baby... How does it feel like bullying a
little girl, huh?
It's good content.
You feel happy?
I'm a kick streamer.
What do you want from me?
I hope you sleep well tonight.
You know what?
I hope you have a nice day.
very threatening it's very polite very polite very sportsman
like don't worry after like a beat down like that I don't
believe it well we got our first cry for today everybody
content everyone was flying it was almost a really good
fight yeah it was very close though like everyone is flying
throwing punches and kicks and uh I honestly thought like uh
there were moments like oh shit um Phelan's gonna win and uh
Ramil oh shit Ramilan's gonna win they were all throwing out
their only one came up on top though but yeah
congratulations to you philian thank you thank you thank you
congrats oh congrats yeah you did amazing even if you are a
child beater but you you can't turn that being script on me
is it 20 i don't want to be here anymore not that dragon
casting stop it stop it why did you pull me as a kid what do
you expect I am not hearing any of these.
Lala, la, la, la.
Yeah, you know what you sound like?
You know what you sound like?
What?
That's what you sound like.
Oh my God.
The track talk is insane.
And yeah, but that was very entertaining.
Yeah, thank you.
Thank you, guys, so much for that.
Thank you.
The match is really fun.
I can't wait to see what how I'm gonna do some more gear.
Yeah, I can't wait for the next matchup.
Like, holy goodness.
Who else is up there in the next matchup?
Who is the next matchup?
See you guys in the finals.
Goodbye forever.
Bye.
Bye-bye.
Okay.
Oh, what's the next matchup here?
it's getting blocked by the assets behind the scenes right
now sorry thank you for whoever is operating in at the
moment sorry we had some little technical difficulties but
here is the next matchup for you guys okay everybody please
fun for her assistance please please she needs next match is
gonna be nagare sarah and justuiji shenru that's another
Hall of Stars member oh my god oh my goodness um not to be
biased or anything but Shinri you have to win win Shinri
Hall of Stars represent baby let's fucking go good luck to
you too um Nagarisara Sora wait how do I read that oh my my
eyes are we um we have my eyes is that Sora or Sarah wait
the share screen Sarah there we go Nagarisara good luck to
both contestants them in here nothing but godspeed for the
interview hello hello um hello where is your man oh is he
not here oh no shenri shenri no not like this after we after
we glazed you like that bro you gotta be here he won't be
available today oh no he has a video oh no no no no there's
some We have him.
He's here, guys.
He's behind the scenes.
He's here, right now.
He's here.
He's here, guys.
Behind the scenes is pinging in.
He's at the area.
Can we get in the voice call right now?
Okay.
All right.
Bring in the Jumbotron.
Well...
Where is it?
Okay, let's get that voice pack going.
Hello.
Shinri, Sara.
Is that how he sounds?
It's me.
I'm gonna fight.
The illness has forever changed.
He's been sick recently, right?
I think so, yeah.
Yeah, okay.
Shinri, I think he's a little bit sick.
Forgive us, guys.
He's just a little bit out of the weather.
There's kind of an epidemic going on in the Hall of Stars.
Introduce yourself, Shinri.
Despite your sickness, Shinri, do you think...
I can't understand, but you're fucking...
Everybody quiet!
What's wrong?
Introduce yourself, man!
The frequencies of your voice!
Sarah, can you... Sarah, do you think you can get a
translation?
Yeah, Joe Suichi Shinri, hey, uh, Hall of Stars, uh, Ronin.
Ronin Hall of Stars, that's me.
Alright, let me try and translate that to everyone who can't
get anything under a base level.
My name's Joe Suichi Shinri, and I'm gonna get my ass
kicked.
Oh!
Are you really going to take that Shinri?
Come on!
Hey, listen, I don't appreciate that.
I don't like that.
You said that about me.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
Why are you so polite?
Hey, Shinri, you're going to try.
Smack talk, Kamsara.
No, I'm Josu Shinri.
I don't smack talk.
You see, there are two kinds of people that we're looking at
here.
So there's two different situations.
Like, if we walked onto a plane, Shinri, I would be a pilot
and you would be be a passenger.
I'm an innovator.
You're an imitator.
I'm a leader and you are, you're a follower.
See, I'm a winner and everyone else here are losers for
believing in one thing.
They believe that Josuichi Shinri can beat me at my own
game.
Are you kidding me?
I'm the best.
Except being a pilot.
A pilot.
Oh my god.
I'm going to fly this plane.
and land it directly into that ring on top of that eager
because I am going to smash it down into a crisp.
Whoa.
This sounds like you're a great pilot.
Oh.
This was a war game.
Reverse dissing.
I just understand.
You said you're a good pilot and apparently it's got blow up
on the ring.
I don't understand.
And everyone's going to come out safely onto the tarmac.
It's a metal horse, Henry.
It's a metal horse.
Okay, that's surpassed my knowledge.
He's a little bit sick.
I'm sorry, guys.
He's a little sick.
Yeah, I'm not feeling good.
Sorry about that, I guess.
A little bit slow.
Hey, hey, hey, I'm not slow.
I'm fast.
I'm going to be the quickest one in the ring.
I guess we'll find out in the match whether you're slow or
fast.
The only way that you're getting out of this ring is by
tapping out or passing out.
See, my wrestler is a fusion of myself and a very
aggressively Bogan Snake.
And once this Boa constricts you, That's it.
Wow.
Well, the only way you're heading out of this ring is by
ambulance.
Oh.
Whoa.
What happened to the, what happened to the nice guy, Shinri?
I thought you were right.
What happened?
Oh, shit.
Nobody says so much.
Yeah.
It'll be, uh, I'll be in the ambulance, uh, trash talking
you while you're in the stretcher.
So let's, uh, let's see how it goes.
All right, Shinri.
Let's, uh, let's save the, uh, trash dog act for later.
All right.
Yeah, yeah, sounds good.
Great.
I'm a Jo Suiji Shinri.
Definitely Jo Suiji Shinri here.
That is him.
I can vouch for him.
Oh, Shinri, kindly give a Koinichiwa to your fans watching
here right now for you.
Oh, yeah, absolutely.
Koinichiwa, everybody.
Jo Suiji Shinri here to do a fight and ready to go.
Feeling great.
Feeling fresh.
Yeah, let's fucking go.
Let's fucking go, everybody.
The match of the century.
between a plane and a Ronin.
Let's see who comes out.
A plane and a Ronin.
I am.
That's what I got from the entire conversation.
Let's go back into the ring.
Let's go.
And the next match, bulk Bogan and Chinri.
What the?
What in the scuba diver?
So is there a scuba diver here?
Chinri, what happened?
What is that pose?
Bogan on that huge bulk and Chinri diving in that deep.
My goodness.
Bogan in a pilot outfit too?
I gotta say though, Chinri is on Brad because he's creeping
up on them opponents like sneaky style, like one of his
horror games.
He's into that one, right?
The following contest is scheduled for one fall.
Introduce a first.
Oh shit, we got to talk.
Presenting somewhat harder than the Sahara from where things
get gory, the gory Sarah Bulk Bogan!
Thank you so much, announcer.
That was great.
Thank you, thank you.
And I can't help but look at the fucking toxic one in the
Jumbo Tron.
Look at that!
What the hell?
Very vocal about the intentions here.
Out here to fucking destroy Shinri.
Poison.
Just poison air.
Not joking around.
Bulk Bogan showing up.
And oh my god!
With a thunderous entrance.
Squatting down and announcing to the world that he is here!
Bulk Bogan better be thankful that she's not a ghost.
Oh my goodness.
This character reminds me.
Yeah, it reminds me of like a Hercules.
Oh my god.
Because of that.
Intense.
What are you doing?
I was going to go to the ring.
You need to walk.
An intimidation factor towards shit.
Oh, what the hell?
Hey, yo, hey, yo.
Hey, yo.
Someone's crawling too.
What the?
Is that the impersonation of a snake?
What's going on?
Is that how a pilot walks?
Oh.
Come on, man.
Fly.
Come on.
Move.
Oh.
They're not moving.
They are.
This is probably the longest.
Fly towards the ring.
like you said there we go there we go the landing sure is
something big necktie it's really wide the short shorts be
doing something oh wow wow do it oh look at that guy
yo they're still sticking to the animalistic behavior though
this is a really long intro yes it is there's a lot of parts
to this uh choreography oh oh wow wow getting the crowd
pumped what she's gonna probably do to shinri is a pump and
dump is what i'm talking about okay a quick pump and dump
them down i hope that's the finisher of their moves Oh no, I
think Shinri might mistake her for a monster or something,
for a ghost or goole.
What is happening here?
It's still going on?
What the hell?
It's still going on.
Oh my god!
You're still crawling?
Stop it!
We get it!
I'm a pilot.
That's definitely not good for her back.
There's still...
Okay.
okay is it done oh wow there's a zoom out yeah kind of it's
still going it's still going she's gonna crawl again look at
her i swear to god if we went into commercial break right
now it's still going yeah yeah here we go their opponent on
a boy failure spree the bloating rodan
I got shot there.
Why'd you have to say that now, sir?
How I see his briefs.
And there's a shirt saying KO, declaring victory right at
once without even saying it.
We got like a fishnets.
Fishnets.
Oh, wow.
Shinri.
Yep, Shinri does that on the daily.
Showing up.
And...
He'd be on that hip set grind set.
And finally, are we up to the match?
Who's going to win?
Will Shinri be able to snorkel his way to victory?
Shinri versus Sara!
Let's go!
And already up the grapple, the referee!
What the fuck are you doing, referee?
Referees just running around.
And immediately, first one to the ground is Sara.
Kick into the chest.
I don't know.
Kidney.
There we go.
You know, you know stuff about kidneys, right?
Yeah, I can produce stones.
Kidney stones.
Okay, okay.
That's enough.
We're here for Shinri and Sarah.
Okay.
We're not here to talk about my medical history.
Thank you very much.
Shinri being very aggressive right now.
Knee to the face!
Disrespect!
Three consecutive kicks.
Ooh.
Ow.
the arm.
Oh, damn.
Kind in the streets.
Shinri is very aggressive with these blows and a knee to the
body as well.
Oh, we.
Ah!
It's a disrespect.
It just keeps going.
Helpful for him.
This is one-sided.
One-sided matchup.
And all that gloating a while ago, Sarah, what happened to
the landing part?
You never landed!
You're crashing down!
And oh, ah!
Oh, not the fingies.
The fingies and to the back.
And the back.
Ooh, those psoas muscles are going to hurt tomorrow.
Ah, miss!
Oh, miss the dive.
Possibly a counter by Sarah.
Got up, grapple, kick to the stomach.
A suplex?
Is that a throw?
Oh!
It's a weird suplex thing.
Another grapple.
And knee to the face yet again.
Knee to the face in this face.
A beautiful face.
A comeback is probably imminent.
Oh, submission.
Oh.
No!
It wasn't a submission.
It was a slam to the arms, aiming for those weak spots.
Dislocated shoulder for Shinri.
Oh, what is happening?
What is happening?
Oh, I didn't even get to see it, but that's probably
painful.
Hey, that's foul.
You know Shinri has aches and his bones and joints.
Using the corner like that, isn't it?
Oh, and they didn't even consider the counts.
Shoulders up.
Shinri is still pumping up with life.
And taking off the shoes.
Sarah, what are you doing?
Don't take off the shoes, please.
Stop!
Stop taking his kicks!
We know what happens when the shoes come off!
You see the toes!
You see the stinky!
Oh!
Ow!
Straight to the turnbuckle.
Oh!
Surprisingly athletic!
No!
We have Sarah here.
He can breathe through those feet.
I didn't think you'd be doing those types of moves.
Oh!
Grab them.
Sarah with the advantage.
Got a counter.
Nice reversal.
It's the torso.
And miss!
He missed the clothesline!
He's blind!
Shinri, come on!
And they flew out!
Okay, follow up.
You need to remove your snorkeling gear.
You can't see!
You can't see.
I think that's gonna debuff your movement, buddy.
Ow!
Face to the mat.
They really do love fighting outside, don't they, Octavio?
Yeah, yeah.
They really like it outside in the air.
And the fucking taunt is insane!
in front of the crowd.
Hyping up the crowd.
I don't know if they're booing or not.
Oh, CBR.
So fucking sinister.
Going on two inches deep.
Bro, hitting the center.
Okay, we go back to the ring.
This is actually a very driven fight.
I'm not sure who will win.
Yeah, me too.
I don't know.
They're like doing a back and forth here.
I think that's going to be a common theme from now on,
considering probably the best fighters are going to be at
the last segment of the show.
Oh, oh, maybe.
you think oh ow we they really do like fighting in the
corners oh what is that to the fucking ground strength to do
was that a finisher oh no they have really good endurance
just a one count just the one every time they pay it's just
one oh and a throw suplex suplex city okay what's happening
we doing it's oh analyzing the competition knee to the face
you love to see it is this a finisher is this it man gonna
oh no it isn't uh it's just a rope choke on that what is
happening uh taking off the submission move that's gotta
hurt that hurts the hamstrings the gastric nemias you're
very knowledgeable about the body parts lots of lactic acid
buildup lactic i don't see any acid but sure buddy and
there's a pin oh i don't see any acid but you see bunch of
lactation no no what are you talking about no one's
lactating anywhere here oh oh finisher finisher is this a
famous nipple twister is it oh no it's not it's not no oh no
oh no no they got away almost you should have attacked the
yeah I think that would be an immediate tap out oh okay oh
what's happening what's happening no simulating the feeling
of drowning I'm expecting finishers here because they've
been dishing out like a lot of hits oh they've probably been
charged up like a long time ago trying to escape through the
ropes we got Sarah here groggy and ah punch a disrespectful
hit to the face what you're gonna do they're joining doing
what is happening oh carrying oh uh straight to the buttock
sarah's back is gonna be splitting and that taunt ah we are
you gonna take that sarah i don't think you should i think
uh you better be fighting back here at any moment or else
there's gonna be the end of you oh there we go it's sarah's
comeback comeback moment grapple again and inside a ring
okay what's Sarah gonna do are they gonna recover is Shinri
gonna recover in time oh no they're recovering time like a
plane okay oh the goggles add extra damage all right that's
gonna sink into your eye sockets on Shinri's face how we how
we oh the stun the stun meter is almost up Oh, ow, and they
are stunned.
Oh, this is it.
I think this is the moment.
Arthritis tomorrow.
This is it.
I think this is the finisher.
Oh, pin.
I think this is the pin.
Oh, no.
What are you doing?
Sarah, what the fuck are you doing?
Pin it down.
No, wait.
That's my senpai.
No, don't pin him down.
Oh, there's blood.
Oh, Shinri's bloodied.
Oh.
The beautiful face.
Now this can populate.
Oh, no, Shinri, this is all your fault.
You're going to lose.
Two.
Oh, kick down.
How did you survive?
still has a fighting chance.
After all that, Shinri is still fighting back.
He's resilient like a Koi.
Like a Koi coming upstream.
Oh, ah!
Ooh, I think that's it.
I think Shinri like that.
The pin is here.
Oh, wait, oh wait, reversal!
Kicked in the butt.
Reversal after reversal.
Or ayo, ayo!
Finisher, this is it!
It's Jover.
so over dragging the body to the middle so it won't get up
yeah let's go one one two slap in the face three and bulk
vogan survived here is your winner representing nagori sarah
bulk vogan we got truly coiver For the Koi.
What is it?
If it's not a snake!
Oh, what the fuck?
What the fuck?
What the fuck is that?
Security.
Show it to the snake.
Don't do that.
We're not a national geographic.
Look at my snake.
Let me whip it out for the camera.
What's that?
What's I tempted Adam in the Garden of Eden.
What the hell is that?
What the fuck was the snake for?
That was like totally irrelevant.
But thank you though.
we're showing off your snake thank you and we have a winner
sarah wow wow that was a long that was a great long match
jesus well yeah it was i like the landing you did so well i
i can't believe you kept your word though you really i mean
you it was like a slow start from when you were entering the
ring but other than that you really pinned him down yeah
that's uh what we in the biz give them the people of shory
like I let them think I let Shinri and his fans think that
uh he could take me on but just dei as I said stuck the
landing stuck the landing and killed him yeah very good sure
your plane did prevail over the coi can't believe it well
I'm so upset I'm so upset um I just I'm sure you are real
Shinri I'm sure you are no Shinri we got you we got you we
got you don't worry i'm shinri yeah yeah you are what the
yeah yes yeah you are i think he has one thing we can we can
comfort each other bro don't worry okay okay i love you I
love you too, bro.
Oh, wait.
No, no.
Not time for that.
Uh, love you too.
I love you.
No, not you.
I love you too.
I love you.
Do you want to like grab coffee?
Oh, wait, was it?
Oh.
Well, it's mine.
Oh, wait.
I'll pay.
Because, you know, I'm just so like ripped and filled up
cash.
Wow.
Yeah.
For you.
Can you please order for me?
No.
Oh, ouch.
I just wanted a coffee with milk.
Well, you guys did amazing, sir.
Congratulations for winning.
Oh, my goodness.
Thank you.
That was very, very interesting.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, very close.
Yeah, so please keep your snake in its, I don't know.
Yeah, where did you get that snake?
Yeah.
Yeah, that was like totally irrelevant.
That came out of nowhere.
Like, I thought you were going to throw it in the scenery.
It didn't.
Like, look at this.
I got a snake with me.
What the fuck?
But was it not epic and memorable, at least?
Dude, your intro was fucking long, too.
Snake on a plane.
Oh, snake's on a plane reference.
Oh.
Whoa.
Just whoa.
That's crazy.
crazy well well insane yeah but thank you guys so much for
participating in the WWE tournament thank you Shinri you've
you tried your best but you know you miss 100% shots of the
you don't take so yeah thank you thank you thank you glad to
have you here even though you're sick thank you oh yeah yeah
thanks thanks for having me uh I'm gonna I'm just shoot you
Shinri I'm gonna I think I should go yeah go rest thank you
go go him Sarah congratulations that was All right.
We'll see you later in the next match.
Yeah.
Congratulations, Sarah.
You're going to proceed to the finals.
So yeah.
Better wait on the second day, everybody.
Let's fucking go.
He didn't hear it.
Wait, what?
What did I?
What?
You talked.
I talked over you.
What?
What did you say?
Nothing.
I was just dunking on you as per usual.
Oh, come on.
Okay.
Let's just go back to the...
I don't need to explain it.
okay next match stop dunking on me we're working together oh
here he is behind the scenes right baby yeah that's right is
currently at nando's uh holo we are gonna go with haka
versus english baby oh no it's him uh yeah it's haka
everybody that's right everybody now down to your fucking
new god how does haka haka how does it feel to win because i
i haven't won it feels fantastic you see i have my previous
loser here and i can't wait to have my brand new loser i
hope they go ahead and do a fucking backflick back to the
ring so i can beat their fucking ass oh what the hell oh
what's happening i don't understand what you just said but
oh no fucking way with that twink baby that's what i'm
fucking saying twink no with a twine i where's phillian oh
um this is backstage i have no idea i need to learn joel
well um look i i will i will did say philly said to let her
know before the match started that her match was gonna be oh
there she is i see her oh she's here all right there she is
wait what's what's happening well well well well well you're
fighting haka isn't that a brand new loser right here i was
really tweaking out back what the frick how about you do a
back club straight to the fucking ring and beat me up huh
what you do off in circus monkey how about you f in i don't
know yeah i don't know man you better prepare a fucking new
vtuber award for the person who's gonna beat your ass in the
ring baby come here talking like that you're gonna win the
award for most curse words said in five minutes why is it so
much dictionary i'm just baffled at like they're back and
forth here i'm pumped i'm i'm waiting are you confident that
you're gonna win again against philian literally they call
me the crow because i'm about to pick those fucking eyes
what bro this is your response this dude just is one like i
don't even know what i'm dealing with right now wait no one
does let me tell you my mom check me they don't know what's
fucking wrong with me but you're gonna figure that fucking
out tonight bro she literally called you over jesus christ
you over you're dumb for it okay that's cool that's cool i
mean we can sell on the ring whatever you want man or maybe
like i don't know like rock paper scissors yeah yeah sure
you know let's see let's see well you're going down how do
you how do you even i'd be nothing no more yeah i need a
translator for a hot to sing we do rock paper scissors loser
gets a finger cut off before we chat bring out google
translate google translate he's speaking english i'm
speaking english just in case just in case just in case we
need we need deep l for haka well i well what's happening
now i might be you know what i might be
be a walled animal but phelian you know what let's have a
let's have a fair fight i hand shake you i hand shake you by
the rules of nature and just prefer the war for me because
i'm gonna beat your fucking ass oh okay all right dude all
right yeah yeah the only guys ready who do you guys think
will win haka or phelian come on win everybody in the
bloodbath of the century stars we're rooting do i get to
cast myself no yeah right what if you win this fight feeling
you get to cast yourself later in the next game hey let's go
you have to learn you have to win it though you have to why
is it for toronto canada i'm not what the wait toronto
canada hey you're not supposed to be here get in the ring
and the following contest is scheduled for one fall
introducing first twinkle twinkle his conquest unmarred Waka
Waka it's Haka Shaka man I love your intros bro thank you
thank you for that Shakira Shakira Shakira introducing his
opponent feeling like a Killian one in a billion if you
blink you'll miss him it's billion let's fucking go let's go
Killian Murphy from another one of that break dancing show
that was presented earlier my goodness they're still
catching up but yeah I'm hoping for the best for Hakka
considering that he is part of our Hall of Stars branch.
So I hope you win.
No bias, but I hope you win.
Good luck, Haka.
Good luck.
I'm rooting for you.
We'll see how Haka cheats this time.
Or will Philean actually turn to tables and actually win
this match?
I feel like Philean will win.
Oh, yeah.
Let's see.
Yeah.
Subversion of expectations.
Those dance moves make Kerr like a really competitive
fighter.
Like she can get out of pins.
can jump she can high fly yeah like the previous match that
we watched with her was like nothing but high flying i
wonder what this match is going to turn out into like a
heavy fighter like a heavy swagger or a lightweighter okay
here we go all right all right we shall see haka versus fion
fight oh wow oh did it Immediately right off the bat.
What happened to the cock, cock, cock.
All I'm seeing is cock, cock, cock.
One of these big throws, high flyer attacks.
Holy crap.
What are you doing?
Haka, you're failing immediately.
To the face.
Oh my god, already smudging the face into the fucking ring.
It's so over.
But we just started, so let us see if this narrative
continues on down the road.
And it hurts.
Those tendons and ligaments are getting torn.
By Philly and the Killian.
Okay, that hurts.
Oh, another one to the face.
Haka barely even fighting back.
Twisting your arm.
Are you okay, Haka?
Oh, break those fingers again.
Oh, my God.
I guess this is what you call like an animal fight.
Like, ah.
Can you reverse it?
No, he's going to do it again.
I ran out of words.
Oh, shit.
Three.
Again, again.
raffles of the same kind why are you still targeting haka's
fingies oh we oh we it's over haka won't be able to use a
spoon and fork again after this fight the reversal like six
is very high oh wow okay finally a comeback the elbow to the
face sizing each other up and phillian again
Never getting back up.
It's going to hurt.
Another somersault technique.
Buns.
Oh, wait.
A pin already.
A pin.
Opportunity.
That could have turned the table.
But no, it's still early and barely any damage has been
done.
It would be a miracle to perform.
Billion just keeps tumbling and rumbling.
And going around.
Rumbling.
Oh.
This might be hot.
It's time to come back.
Do a comeback.
Oh.
on the turnbuckle salvo punches this corner may be his only
chance of winning it back and no he got punched into the gut
and oh he got caught and an elbow to the chest straight to
the heart oh really focusing on the arms there I'm sorry
Hakka it's over I think this is probably impossible for you
to come back to unless unless you pull something through
okay is this a glimmer of hope a glimmer of hope is this a
light here at a very dark tunnel oh oh wait oh oh god back
up oh well instead of recovering from philian didn't even
feel that oh oh we okay here's a pin here's a pin
A kick out.
Kick out of the pin.
And surprisingly, it didn't have a count.
Surprisingly resilient of Haka.
Oh.
Billion throwing him.
Haka throwing back.
Somersaulting.
What is going on in Haka?
Are you okay?
Oh, moon kick.
Oh.
Haka was funny there.
It was like, right.
Oh, this might be it.
Yeah, this is it.
That wasn't even a match.
That was like a fucking massacre.
Oh!
Still going!
So slow!
What?
Somebody fire the referee!
Haka!
I gotta admit, you're pretty fucking strong here.
Like your durability on your character is just super fucking
weird.
What is your statistics, man?
And jump in!
It's a flip-flops.
Oh, countered.
Oh!
That flip only caused you a lot.
like a damage to the chest.
Because his toes are free.
Oh!
Stun meter going up!
Now get her into the ring and pin her down!
Is he going to get the momentum ready?
Three seconds outside!
Oh, taunting?
Taunting?
Oh!
Right in front of the top!
That disrespect is real!
Oh my god!
Leverage pin!
Reverse pin!
These pins are very short.
Not even a one count.
Ooh, ah, reversal.
Reverse elbow to the face yet again.
Eh.
Back shot.
Stop it.
Oh!
We're having corner attacks here.
One more?
Turnbuckle attacks.
Oh, there's one more.
One more?
Announcing another finishing strike.
And here it is.
Pin, down for the count.
Is it really down for the count?
This is it.
This might be it.
One, two, three!
billion one wow that was a one-sided match here is your
winner did i stutter she makes her heart what a billion
billion damn congratulations or is she a dog i don't know
she's but yeah that animal that animal right there is that
dog they got that dog on her nose
she's got that dog in her let's fucking go she's very
penetrating yeah wow so what do you say nah that shit was
fucking rigged let me tell you dude the way the way spillion
threw at me with like fucking triple backshot loss of nature
with the triple bell buckle that was not fair that was an
illegal move i mean that's not the only illegal thing that's
been um well i i'm just saying how how does it feel like
losing even though you shit talked to her so much well you
see i i should have put the energy on shit talking on the
actual fight it seems like i was a little bit um like not
not balanced you know what i'm talking about the stats
really didn't help me on here but come on look at philium
man philium's like you got brutalized bro i was really
impressed by your he wants and he wanted he would literally
have to be in the same like way like category but this
doesn't work like this over here he keeps talking you know
he's not capping bro you're fucking lost he's still going
you're fucking wrestling man i cannot think no more i cannot
think no more man i mean you're on her head she's not in
your head get out of my head listen here's okay they put me
against a kid the first time i didn't know they do it again
like i'm sorry yes i matched this man the child allegations
oh wait no the chat way no you know what what let's just
stop there what are you trying to say um uh well how does it
feel how does it feel to be the child yeah you tell him He's
like, you're my girlfriend.
Frick you.
Ooh.
Damn.
That was a little bit personal.
I walked myself to the hospital.
That was awkward.
Thank you for having me.
I walked myself to the hospital.
It's way too close to home.
This dog has taken hands.
Let me tell you that.
Well, the fight was amazing.
I think the Leon's moves are really, really cool.
And I can't wait to see how far.
I think I think he'll get pretty far Philly in.
Yeah, I could tell too.
High flyer and heavy hitter.
Damn, the combination of the statistics is fucking good.
Like you don't even give Hawkeye a chance.
Impressed as hell.
It's a really, really like exhausting fucking sport.
So you're doing you're doing your best.
I'm proud of you.
Oh, frick.
Yeah.
No, it was great being you two, by the way.
Well, then are we are we ready for our next fight?
Are we ready for the next fight?
Who's the next one?
Who's ready to battle?
Who's next in the...
Oh, wait, oh, wait, wait.
Phelian, right?
Like, she's going to go casting?
Wait, is it my fight?
Yeah.
I think it is.
We're just...
It's my fight.
Oh, you're casting your own fight.
Let's fucking go!
We're just waiting for your opponent.
Am I going to cast my own fight?
I think.
I think so.
Well, now that you're here, let's see.
I want...
I want to see your match, Octavio.
I want to see it.
Like, I want to see your live reactions to everything.
Like, how are you going to face against a dragon?
I mean, dragon's kind of like a dinosaur.
So kind of easy to...
So can you take him on?
You guys do look like siblings.
I can just cut off their tails.
Their wings.
But no, the difference was I fucking lost.
So I don't think that's a parable.
What's up?
There she is.
what octavia what happened to the toughness i thought you
were ready come on bro come on she waited her face say it
man hello what do you have to say cyrox what's up bro what
happened to the aggression what happened dude you were you
were talking such mad shit and unlike social media you have
nothing to say now now that she's standing here you're just
You're a dragon.
You know, you're more like a baby worm.
You're actually more like a worm.
I'm going to crush you beneath my heel of my boot.
Ah, don't talk back, please.
So you're going to...
That was pretty good.
Really?
I can appreciate you after.
Thank you.
You're just going to...
You're just going to get...
I'm not accepting anything.
I don't know.
Just accept it.
No, man.
Yay!
I win.
I don't have anything to say to you.
I don't know.
Oh, you're worthless!
I'll take it!
She literally called you!
Worthless, not even worth the attention, bro!
Are you gonna accept that?
Not even worth the reply?
How dare you!
Bro, bro!
I'm gonna burn!
That fucking disrespect is insane.
I don't think I'm right now.
Bro, literally said hello to me.
Oh, uh...
Stop doing this, tell me!
Come here, my arguments!
The first thing you did was like stutter to me.
Like you saw me draw and you're like, oh, oh, holy crap.
What do I do?
I can't believe this.
You are an embarrassment, bro.
Come on, not like this.
Not like this.
Come on, Sia, let's go to the ring.
I'm going to clip your damn wings.
I'll let my fists do all the talking.
Oh!
I ain't got no...
I'm not going to make my puppets do my talking.
I have puppets.
They're cute and cuddly.
Yeah, yeah.
They can fight.
for me good for you bro that's great i'm so happy for you
wait anyway guys chat gpt help me who do you think based on
this conversation right here octavio or sya place in your
votes right now good luck sya come on you got this please
please I'm hoping for the best for Sia too.
Let's fucking go.
Octavio, you're going to go down.
I don't know what you're saying to me, bro.
Damn, look at that.
Look at that.
Very handsome man.
Octavio, your face.
What happened to your face?
I don't know.
I'm slaying.
Slay.
Wait.
I think I'm catching a glimpse of what you really look like,
bro.
You mean fabulous.
Look at my three braids.
Can you see?
Yeah.
like I don't like it I don't like it that's I have a painted
body I I don't like it I don't like it oh the following
contest is scheduled for one fall introducing first from the
announced desk one brutal ratio Octavio look at that guy
what a what a stand He be glowing!
Oh shit!
Hey!
Dude's got that zoom-ins!
Look at my puppet!
Oh, there it is!
This is so on brand, by the way.
Holy crap.
I'm gonna make it fight for me.
What happened?
It disappeared!
Bro!
Where'd it go?
I threw it away!
I didn't see it!
Okay, alright, alright.
Look here from Octavio.
Okay, what are you going to do?
Do you have a...
Oh, there it is.
There's the gimmick.
There it is.
Oh, menacingly looking up to the crowd in a wink.
I directed those pyrotechnics.
See?
Oh, wow.
A lot of budget went to the outfit.
Wow, wow, wow.
I think this guy is going to win.
Just my feeling.
Let's see what Sia looks like.
Let's see, because sometimes the build determines the match.
He's going crazy.
You're still going.
I don't know, man.
Look at all my strings, see?
I'm going to attach those to Sia.
I'm going to win without even touching her, without even
punching her.
Mm-hmm.
Oh, oh, bro, I don't want to look at the polls right now.
I think you're in a fucking, oh no.
getting bodied, everyone, everyone has zero faith in you.
Introducing his opponent.
The WWE Universe.
Whoa.
From hell.
Bruh.
She is the Slayer Seah!
Holy crap.
Wow, you brought in a torch.
What do you mean from hell?
She's from a little cave.
Oh my god!
Bro, stop burning the stage!
Shout out to the mom out here!
Your daughter's lighting up the fucking stage.
Dude, does your mom know you're V-tubing?
The arena is burning.
Does your mom know you're V-tubing?
Yes.
Mine doesn't.
No.
Imagine if she actually stumbles onto this WWE stream.
Are you ashamed of yourself?
Of course I am.
Mom, it's not what you think.
Excuse me.
It's not what you think.
VTubers are the cool kids.
Oh, I'm doing voice acting, mom.
I swear.
VTubers are the new jocks.
I make money, mom.
Not a phase, I swear.
Entering the ring.
And no pyrotechnics.
I guess she loses in terms of like...
She's big and bulky again.
Look at that.
She's going to be tall, I swear to God.
It's gonna be seven feet tall.
Is she gonna be?
And I'm just gonna be five, five, eight.
Here we go.
Oh, wow.
They're both doing the same thing.
But the only winner is one.
Who are they gonna be?
Oh, kick.
Oh, my God.
It made it start.
And they're having a cat fight.
Oh, ripping off the hair.
Oh, not the hair.
Ripping off the arms.
Clipping the arms.
wings of an angel reversal grapple and oh oh my god octavia
you might actually fucking win oh my god oh my god dude's
flexing out here buddy guys guys i think the statistics in
the voting system is false octavia may have a chance here a
butt dive oh oh twist in the neck yeah dislocate that head
Here it is.
Is it a tap out?
Remove that dragon's head.
Oh, no.
It wasn't a tap out.
There we go.
It wasn't a submission move.
Yes.
Oh, Stunner.
Oh, is this a finisher?
Is this a finisher?
Oh, no.
It's just a taunt.
Octavio with the aggressive play here bashing in.
Oh, my God.
Here's a pin already.
One and a kick out.
Sia, if you ever want to win, you better fight back because
Octavio's on a fucking roll here and a smash on those arms
let's go oh oh oh we went do i still not deserve a request
oh my god and a head bash oh god animalistic behavior by
smashing the head head oh my god here we go oh no don't do
this to me and a barely a scratch to Octavio.
You're going to have to do more than that to actually do
some more.
Went past by GamerSuffs.
Offered by GamerSuffs,
Aggression.
Athleticism is being shown to the screen.
They're both still fighting outside.
Ooh!
Pull those strings, puppet man.
Nothing but dirty plays.
And...
It is dirty play.
This is all legit.
You're not fighting into the stage.
No, that's not allowed.
Oh, they're back in.
Okay, they're back in.
Oh, Octavio, what are you doing?
Octavio, you arrogant prick, get inside a ring.
Pin him.
Pin him down.
Oh!
Damn!
Is this it?
Oh, high flyer technique!
Oh, he's gonna dive.
Oh shit!
It's over, it's so over.
And a pain, one, two!
Oh, kicked out!
There may be hope here for Sia fans out here.
And doing a taunt of all things!
The absolute confidence is in this motherfucker.
Stay in your, stay in your fictionary books.
Fictional books.
Where you belong.
Throw in the corner and another punch.
nothing oh no I feel so sorry for Sia right now oh wait come
back come back oh no is it is it oh my head we got a grapple
technique here but not enough to actually put him in a
stunning stage so far we've seen Octavio body Sia what's
happening I don't know they're just going in and out in and
out what's going on But it's something.
Oh, no!
Don't put me on the...
And head to the turnbuckle.
Oh, damn.
What are you doing, Sia?
What are you doing?
Sia, what are you doing?
Sia, I think you're...
Oh, my God.
What the hell?
Is this it?
Oh, no!
No!
Oh, shit!
Oh, I'm stunned.
Is this it?
One trick pony!
One!
Oh!
Just a one count.
Good job, good job.
Okay, what are you doing?
Not even worth a second count.
Position her correctly.
Oh no.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, reversal!
Ayo!
Octavio!
Damn.
Okay, more of this?
Oh, wow, the ref is in the fucking way.
Yeah, the ref was in the way.
Get out of the way!
Submission!
Is this it?
Oh!
No, no, it wasn't a tap out.
She got out.
Durability high.
Ooh!
An exchange of blows.
A slap in the face.
Ooh!
Come on!
Let's go!
Ay!
Why'd you punch me?
Nothing but back and forth here.
And a counter.
Oh!
Oh, I'm blooded.
River's blood!
Nothing but blood!
Oh!
Oh, it's so over.
It's so over.
There's... Oh shit!
Whoa!
That's it!
It's over!
I flew.
Stunner is real.
Oh, not my legs, not my legs.
Oh, no, no.
Okay, this match is gonna be probably a... Oh, Rivers!
Oh!
This match is closer than I expected.
I thought this is gonna be a Oh, is this it?
Oh, is it?
One, two.
Oh, kick out.
Damn it.
Please, help me.
Unfortunately, Octavia, you're going to have to fight for
that one.
Why is this such a hard battle?
Rapping each other again.
Throw it again.
Into the corner.
Octavia with the advantage.
Doing a little dance.
What the fuck?
Get puppeteered.
And boom.
It's over.
It's that.
Oh, what are you doing, referee?
One, two, three.
Swift, Tavio advances to the next round.
Here is your winner, Octavio.
That's the fearless fit there.
Shout out to Mother Taylor Swift.
Oh, Ks.
Octavio.
You're in love for Taylor Swift now.
ever see us to disappoint them it's fearless that was a
great great ranking yeah it was a great match great job
kindly a little just a little bit disappointed though i had
high expectations that you'd lose you look so dumb i hate
your character design octavio i hate it how'd you win
well um hey saya that was definitely a thought That was a
lot of back and points.
Are you now going to reply to my fire insults?
She doesn't even care, bro.
I want to know.
I won.
Please?
Say something at least.
Say something.
He won.
He at least earned it.
You need help being escorted out of the building without...
I need help.
I can help you.
Get out of here.
I need help, please.
I got you.
I'll cover you in everything.
Call me stinky, call me small, call me bad, call me, I don't
know.
And you're calling me a masochist, Jesus Christ.
You're begging for insults.
Bro!
Well thought.
No!
Learn some humility.
We're in another chat.
What's the line?
I feel like I lost.
Any afterthoughts after this fight?
No.
I have no thoughts.
Just depression.
No thoughts.
That entire fight felt like no thoughts had empty.
Bam.
Indifference hurts more.
Yes, it does, bro.
That's crazy.
I won, but I lost.
I guess, Octavio, congrats on winning.
Dude, that's a fucking trumpet.
I'm sorry.
I'm really happy for you, Octavio.
Really do.
I hope you perform better in the next match.
Thank you.
We done now.
Are we done glazing you?
Congratulations.
You won.
You won, buddy.
You're happy now?
Well, thank you for joining us.
You're amazing and you're super slay.
Thanks for having me.
Thank you.
You're not beating me.
Yeah, bye bye, Sayah.
Bye bye.
Oh, man.
The next match.
Next match.
Oh, shit.
I'm excited for this one.
What is happening?
Why?
Okay.
Oh, what?
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh, what?
Yeah.
Battle two.
The twins are here.
I thought that was a joke.
What the fuck?
Are they here?
It's real.
They're actually here?
Oh, my fucking god.
Betal one and Betal two.
Hey, everybody.
Good to see.
Wait, no.
Excuse me.
No, no.
I've been suffering from a terrible call.
I just been having a hard time recently.
Hey, everybody.
How's it going?
Yeah, you're going to be suffering from a little bit more
after this.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Trash talking starts immediately.
Listen, listen, listen.
We might be twins, but we are also fraternal twins.
That means our fighting styles will be different.
And frankly, frankly, this is payback for taking all the
nutrients in the womb.
I mean, you're not going to use them.
twins relate everybody twins relate well would you like to
explain how your uh fighting styles differ well mine is a
winning style and his is a losing style so it is kind of a
drastic difference if you if you catch my drip well we'll
we'll see brother we'll see which one of us has the
recessive genes and the dominant ones well i don't even know
what that means i don't even know what that
This is a family feud for sure.
It is personal.
It sure is.
It's personal.
I know you guys are fighting.
This is a rivalry that started from the womb.
Oh, God.
The tomb.
Well, I know you guys are fighting, but how does it feel to,
you know, be in the same room as each other after a while?
You know, terrible.
Oh.
Honestly, awful.
It's really bad.
I honestly, this guy's been pissing me off for too long.
I'm done with that.
It was a surprise to be here.
And I'm not, not a good surprise, a bad surprise that I have
to fight him, honestly.
Stray you in there!
You're gonna die!
They love each other.
Yeah.
And I love him.
I love him.
Aww.
None of that, ooh, sucky-wucky stuff here.
It's all violence.
Oh, okay.
Well.
Well, I wish both of you the best of luck.
I definitely don't have bias and who wins in this match
either, but...
I'm curious, though.
Yeah.
you who's the strongest twin we will find out everybody put
in your votes who's gonna win battle one or battle two put
in your votes everybody there we go there we go while that
is running any final words nothing okay why am i losing the
poll we both know why you're losing the poll come on holy
crap what is that abomination the poll is up and running and
just just for the sake of it i'm just gonna vote for battle
let's see let's see the oh my god that is a large martial
battle too is winning oh my god looks handsome what a damper
fellow he has a kick too holy shit let's fucking go let's
see who's gonna win battle between brothers twin versus twin
a battle a battle that began the following contest is a twin
wins match for one fall introducing first.
He is the bipedal gas pedal battle one.
That's horrifying.
It is.
What is his face?
I'm just looking at it in horror.
What the hell is that?
What is that?
His face is just plastered on human, on a human head.
What the hell?
Does he have like a skin suit that he's wearing over his
head or face?
There's a fucking skin walker.
Introducing his opponent straight from the same room, the
rebel who meddles Battle 2!
Wow, this is really nice!
Very unexpected turn of events.
I didn't think we'd be seeing Battle 2 fight Battle 1.
I thought it was like a joke at the beginning.
And it turns out it's actually fucking real.
Yeah, it's like a battle versus battle and his own character
creation.
But look at this right now.
A surprising turn of events.
This is so weird.
This battle two looks more British than the battle one.
The winner should replace the battle.
Oh.
Yeah, that should be a thing.
This is a battle to beat a battle.
Who's going to beat a battle one?
All bets on Tubert.
Yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, let's go.
Let's go.
All right.
I'm excited to see.
Here it is.
The Battle of the Century.
On this corner is Battle.
And on that corner is Battle 2.
Fight.
Oh, my God.
They did the same thing!
Twins through and through!
Battle of the Century and a Kick!
They share the same genetics!
Oh my god, this is hype as hell!
Battle 1 turns out to be the Battle 1!
And he's the way of sub-assault!
High flyer Battle 1!
High flying technique!
With a creepy ass face!
Right in the nuts!
Right in the groin!
Oh!
I can't... This is the most... I like that they started out
just sprinting towards each other.
Like, their immense hatred for each other is just that
strong.
They immediately just started running.
They didn't even think!
They just did the same technique without even thinking.
That is insane.
That's... that's what they did in the womb.
Who started kicking first?
Betel or Bell?
Bell 2.
Ask your mom.
At the same time.
Mom, who kicked first?
Oh, apparently, Betel 2 kicked first.
And whoa!
Battle mom, who do you love more?
Battle one or battle two?
Who's your favorite?
Oh, shit!
Oh, goddamn.
God damn.
Now they're outside.
A little bit of a hug.
A sweet family reunion moment.
And oh, oh, not really.
And oh!
They do not really love each other at this moment.
This is a hype as hell battle.
It is.
Blood rivalry has always been like the hype as shit.
Like, who is the most dominant between like, um, siblings?
and shift they've always been compared that's so aggressive
aggressive and personal they're considering their emotions
oh that's a great taunt going back into ring giving him a
chance oh riding on that back oh smash the face kicking two
Burton to the ground pummeling him down raiding supreme oh
he just jumped oh went back inside what is this back what is
behavior back to your place oh tuber as expected of a that
was a huge fumble but Willis fumble though oh because he
wears glasses they both fumbled the same person I can't tell
which one is which
Oh, they didn't even give him a chance to stand up.
The disrespect.
Leg locking him.
Oh.
Ow.
He's not going to be standing up for a few seconds.
Oh, oh, oh, arm, arm, arm.
Twisting.
Oh, you're going to dislocate that arm.
Oh, what?
And a taunt here and there.
Who do you think is going to win, Octavio, based on the
current fight right now?
still rooting for battle one better one because i kind of
like changed my opinion right now i think battle two is
going to make a uh a title change right here like a swift
change of like events oh whoa okay take it back take it back
oh battle's gonna win battle's gonna win is battle gonna
jump battle's gonna jump oh censored oh god damn i can't see
it get your Fucking sign on my screen!
Don't do this at home, kids.
Oh, clothesline.
That clothesline was really hard.
Oh, shit.
Oh, God.
Eyo!
Oh, he just walked away.
Not even worth running.
Not even...
Oh, what are you doing?
In the size of Betelgeuse.
Oh, what the fuck are you doing, Betelgeuse?
Betelgeuse!
This is scripted.
That's so stupid.
loves Gavis Battle.
Tubert, I know you love your brother, but you don't have to
fumble that, obviously, alright?
Alright?
He failed to land it.
Now we know who's gonna win.
Oh!
They both jumped at the same time, but doing the pin is
Tubert 1!
And a count to 1.
Just a 1 count.
Bettle is more sturdy than I thought.
You guys see is but to be fair they have not landed a
finisher just yet and look at that look at that headstand
flexing and he's dead no he's not his c3 is hurting oh oh
dirty move dirty move that took him out wait for a battle to
show his signature move the low blow oh oh that is the
finisher is this
Three!
Battle one!
Win the battle of the battle!
Here is your winner!
Battle only winner!
That was a nice fight though.
Even though it was short, that was like a very hype as hell.
I hope they don't have any hard feelings though after this.
I hope nothing personal ever happened to you.
between them after this match own who let's see let's hear i
don't know the plot twist continues
i may have been born second but i just gave it first whoa
whoa whoa actually a real actual cannon holy crap it is what
it is i guess you know sometimes you win sometimes you lose
today was my day i guess wow wow wow i feel kind of i feel
kind of bad i feel i mean it's all right do you want to talk
about it no no it's okay all right i i didn't okay i just
got i think i got caught up in the competitivity i didn't
really check on no no i just thought that we would you know
it was a big day for us both here and i just thought we were
gonna play it out a little bit more yeah i well i i oh geez
that really hurt like i don't know you i thought you'd
agreed that wasn't gonna um we were gonna hold back just a
little Alexa play despacito please all right play despacito
so sad uh we that well I uh I I won I won but I won't cause
mr.
battle uh you know drop family lore drop holy crap I could
always find another brother oh Yeah.
Well, damn.
You guys did amazing.
It was very, it was a very, very even, even match.
Yeah.
Evenly matched.
Literally and metaphorically.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
It only relied on the person who would do the finisher first
and Bell came out on top.
Yeah.
I was really surprised when you both did the same move at
the beginning.
That was sick.
Yeah.
That was cool.
I didn't think you'd be doing the same moves.
Was that planned or was it not?
Like, let's talk about this.
Let's use the same technique.
i mean i mean you know we're twins we're thinking the same
thing we had a psychological advantage on each other yeah oh
yeah it's twin things i guess but what we can't take away is
that the winner is bettel saying that you should be careful
what you drink very true bettel is the winner everybody
everybody congratulations to bettel thank you thank you all
right well i'm gonna go uh go get some rest and battle too
uh thanks for fighting me yeah it was fun yeah it was both
entertaining and fun having both of you here thank you thank
you thank you all right well thanks see you in the next
fight battle all right bye bye thank you and next we have
the next it's dokey and here it is everybody the moment
you've been waiting for
Versus!
What is this?
It's cute though.
It's cute.
That's Axel Senpai.
What?
What the fuck?
We postponed you like four times Axel.
Yeah.
Yo.
Okay.
First of all, let me say, hey, nice to meet you, man.
You know, it doesn't feel like a first time shopping.
met you know yeah i feel like i've heard this thing before
i've uh yeah i i just don't know it's somewhere and you know
this guy hasn't even digested his chicken yet and he's here
to fight me like oh it's a pre-game it's a pre-game meal
it's like when you eat and you're not supposed to go to the
swimming pool you're not supposed to wrestle after eating
this guy doesn't take this seriously nah this is a series
dude i gotta win after this dude i know half of the boys
slaughtered bro now yeah yeah we do you know all my
disciples all my sons they all got fucking slaughtered
except like one or two you know now as the sensei you know i
gotta come out and win for them you know what i'm saying you
better senpai i gotta channel hell yeah baby you know i
gotta fucking channel my inner steve irwin and fucking
tackle you down like a little fucking crocodile.
He fucking died to a stingray.
I just have to poke you in the fucking heart.
Like, what do you do?
You don't look like a stingray.
I can just fucking punch you in the heart and you're fucked.
He's dead.
You look like the chicken I had at Nando.
Oh, shut yo, Big Rasa.
Bring your ass.
You look like the chicken I had at Nando's today.
Wow.
Damn fucking right.
I hope you get a stomach ache for a night because you didn't
digest it properly.
All the time, baby, all the time.
I hope you get a kidney stone from that dandos.
Nah, I'm drinking water.
Why am I getting hit?
Why?
Why specifically killing kidney stones?
I'm a fucking hydro homie.
I drink water every day nonstop, you know?
Yeah, I like this guy.
Alcohol's not water.
Well, true, true.
Well, true.
Nah.
We're fucking going down.
I saw what you're wearing tonight in the ring.
You're going down.
Check out my fit.
I got it from Gucci.
Straight out of Gucci.
Oh, yeah.
They're going to see what you got from Gucci.
Hell yeah.
Bro.
I didn't even buy it.
They just gave it to me for free.
They're like, yo, sponsored by us.
Oh, no.
When they see, when all of them see what they gave you for
free, don't know why it was for free.
I mean, hey, look at my pose, yo.
i'm giving you that zesty little meow looking ass pose bro
i'm out here for some zest tonight and i'm gonna get your
ass just like the chicken i had at nando's like i said bring
your ass just like the stingray to steve uran i'm gonna kill
you in game oh whoa whoa whoa in game in game in game thank
you for the clarification but let's see the uh statistics on
the uh poll right here and thinks that Doki's going to win
by 65% over 35% but we will see everybody let's believe the
underdog story you know what I'm saying look at the way bro
bro I'm just saying you're just a dog Axel that's bad for me
hey hey shut up shut up bet for me and you make that money
shout out to Kabus what the fuck Oh, that's so cute.
That's so cute.
Oh, it's so cute.
I didn't think you could do that.
Oh my god.
We got Axel here.
Everybody change the statistics now.
Vote for Axel.
This is a cute image.
Continuation of Tekken 8.
But yeah.
Let us now continue.
Let's go.
Go King versus Axel.
He's so serious.
Dog.
Let's see his fit.
He says it comes from Gucci.
We'll see about that.
Let's see.
damn this is hype yeah the loading screen is intense who the
following contest is scheduled for one fall what's a one
fall she is the Ayatollah of the tuberola her heart makes us
go joky joky She is the word Donkey
Bear And here she is Rising ever so slowly Very dramatic And
she is the king Flat tiger face That very Where's the snout?
Poorly rendered tiger face You can't see the snout I can't
But goddamn that is very intimidating and terrifying looks
like someone will fucking rob me in the fucking middle of
the night Jesus Christ nothing special and there it is damn
there it is pyro techniques on point the pyro look at those
muscles no roaring oh shit I know that it's Cody Rhodes Cody
Rhodes Cody Rhodes entrance
very fucking nice on that the hype is immense I can't wait
who's your bet who's your bet I think I'm gonna bet on Doki
for this one I'm gonna bet on Axel just because he's my
senpai I'm gonna vote I can't I can't I can't it's one of
the rules sorry guys her opponent Get good.
The Zest in the world!
Oh my god.
Actually serious!
Axel Seria!
Oh wow!
What the heck?
He brought out the bomb stick!
Dude, that is so cute!
That's not Gucci, that's Gucci.
What the fuck are you talking about?
That's not what it means!
Stop!
Where the fuck is the Koochie part?
Octavio!
Damn.
You're not helping.
You're not...
This stream is so demonetized because of you.
Furry confirmed.
He's very convincing, man.
He's ready and raring to go.
But hey, he's got that dog in him, though.
Wait, it has Axel's hair on the dog.
Yeah, it's poorly textured, but it's there.
Damn, you even got the chains.
like Kurapika all right battle between the furries he's
naked who's gonna win naked the king and immediate beat down
from Doki pummeling his face running yeah this is a furry
battle battle the furries it is technically oh wow I'm just
looking at Axel's clothes.
Whoa, that's a cool attack.
It looks like a fucking dog, bro.
Those back muscles are crazy.
It is though.
Like isn't that like a just a suit though?
Yeah, it's just a suit.
It's just a muscle suit.
It's not even real.
It's really thin inside.
Rubbing it.
Rub your face.
Oh Stun meter is up.
Elbow to the back.
match slamming the face the back of the head to the stage a
mad dog oh almost stunned here everybody what is that time
oh dokey better get up oh whoa counter counter the stock
meter is going away who's just stepped on him okay here we
go dokey's really here we go here we go here we go It's got
a heart.
Bunch of chains on there too.
Oh shit.
Needs in a face.
Even landed on it.
My goodness.
That body weight.
Oh, even they're both dishing each other's attacks on the
fucking face.
Whoa.
They're grabbing each other.
Ah, no.
Countered.
Oh, technically a hit, but a miss.
Will it be enough?
Hold on to the rope.
Oh, he can't get more than that.
Okay, it wasn't enough.
Oh, oh, oh.
Throw him to the ringside.
And knee to the face.
What is that?
Oh, my God.
A quick leverage out of the way.
He recovered for that.
Both heavy hitters.
Oh, this is going to hurt.
This is going to hurt.
Carry.
Oh, the railing.
Is that allowed?
Disqualification.
You're using.
That should be disqualification.
right or am I wrong my god they just left him out there and
just oh fucking spear launching oh that's gotta hurt Pia
watch out animal abuse that's pure cement there oh could you
guys please stop not the metal oh my god that is personal oh
Wow.
This feels like old wrestling.
The beautiful face.
Okay, okay.
The old days of wrestling.
We're back, we're back.
This might be it.
Oh, what's an attack?
Oh, what the fuck?
Axel doing a taunt.
Is it worth it?
You could have used that time to actually, oh, grinding the
face!
Don't do that to the Jaguar face.
Doki, can you survive?
one two oh kick out kick out come on man not quite you're
voting for dokey right you better cheer on man we'll see
we'll go dokey still has a chance oh was that the balls i
have no idea oh hamstrings okay i thought they were the
balls okay okay oh oh a spear oh this is this is technically
one-sided as it is i don't know look look she still has some
fighting her look look there we go to activate that rage on
oh rage on rage on oh my god stun meter is back up baby oh
back to the railing again you have to continue the pummel
pummeling will actually stun Axel if this continues and oh
nothing happened what the fuck and Axel gain the advantage
again the game bugged before it before she could even fight
back what happened what happened was um she she threw Axel
to the uh to the stairs and it didn't like uh hit like it
didn't activate like she he didn't get stunned he was
supposed to get stunned but didn't
King, you better get up.
How many seconds have you been outside?
Two.
Oh, okay, two.
It got reset.
The dog loves it outside.
The match is rigged against Doki.
And Opah!
Stun!
But she's outside.
You need to get her in.
Four.
Well, she's going to stand up.
The stun meter is refreshed.
They're going back in.
Doki?
Oh, is Doki running away?
Oh no!
Axel, let her in!
Resetting the timer!
Axel's not giving Doki a chance!
Come back!
Come back in real!
Oh, it wasn't enough.
Gravel, is it in favor of Axel or...
Oh, it's in favor of Doki.
I think this might be the final thing.
Is it?
Oh, yeah!
Oh, another one.
Another one.
This is like...
Suplex continuous.
And another one.
This is definitely King!
King from Tekken!
It's Jover!
Oh, stunned.
The finisher has been sent.
Pin, pin, pin, pin.
Is it enough?
One, two, three!
Stop slapping the dog's face, referee.
Please, please, you're not helping.
Not gonna lie, that move though kind of reminds me of King
from Tekken.
The unlimited combo grapple.
Oh my god!
attack from such a big person.
This is it, this is it.
A finisher, I know this one.
It's a default finisher.
Oh!
No, it isn't!
Again, again, again!
One more in a three.
Oh, one more.
This is it, this is it!
Three, Dokey wins!
Sorry, Axel.
This is the end.
This is it.
This is over.
Oh!
Pin, pin, pin, pin, pin.
Stand up!
What are you doing?
Dokey knocked out!
Dokey!
What?
Axel, what?
Oh!
Huh?
I'm so confused.
This doesn't make any sense!
What's happening?
This game is rigged!
This tournament is rigged!
Axel's gonna win!
Ooh!
Pin!
Doki, I'm...
I'm thinking that you have a plan.
But Axel get your shit together because you are gonna lose!
Sampai!
Axel is getting pummeled.
Axel isn't fighting back!
Oh no!
Senpai!
TATAKAE!
Oh, nothing's happening.
He's still stunned.
Oh shit!
Another finisher!
This is so painful to watch!
Oh!
Why?
Axel might win!
Oh shit, it's over.
It's- Oh!
Another spear.
Oh, here we go.
And oh!
Is Doki stunned enough to not get into the ring?
After 10 counts?
Oh, and she's stunned.
She's stunned.
Axel's doing the finisher.
Oh, Axel's gonna do the finisher.
The finisher, he's waiting!
What?
And slammed!
Choke slam!
Put her in the ring!
Oh shit.
Damn!
oh here we go this is it this is this it what is this it oh
my god he's nodding off the fingers oh my god
this is a long battle it is it is there's so many moments
where doki was in oh here there it is here we go oh there's
a fumble i could already tell is this a fumble
Oh, Axel.
Oh, he's dead.
He's down.
He's doing.
That's it.
He's doing it.
Okay.
It's it.
It's over.
One, two, three, three.
The trash talker loses again.
Here is your winner.
She is the word.
Dokey.
Bad.
Dokey came up.
Out on top, baby!
Wow, four out of five.
Amazing.
That was intense, intense.
I've never seen like an animal matchup before.
The only holostars in play are me and Betel.
Guys, you better, you better.
All right, let's switch on to the interview section.
Everybody, let's go.
The donkey!
Oh, what can I say?
Let's go!
Just like Steve Urin.
How are you doing?
Axel?
You got Steve Urin?
God damn!
I must ask, how was it, you know, fighting in a fursuit?
Steve, I'm sorry to keep you waiting.
I'll be there soon, man.
Just wait for me.
Just try to keep you waiting.
Honestly, you know, I was like, yo, I have to give it up,
right?
I mean...
Give up the ghost.
I made some big money.
Why do you have to give it up though?
Oh, you fucking threw it!
Oh, I don't know.
Somebody is sandbagging you!
I don't know.
But guys!
There are so many more games still left.
Make sure to use the app, B-Bets, to get your best bets on
B-Bets now, today!
no this is already falling apart go for the underdog that's
what i'm saying go for the underdog you make some big money
on the underdog yo oh my god he did this on purpose he
talked mad so people would vote against him you know me what
the bro you know he's a business man he got the money yeah
he's a business thinking hell yeah you know me hey but that
you know that gucci suit i can sell it off as well make a
couple of extra bucks i mean it's all business at the end of
the day you know yeah the gucci first suit the gucci first
suit i didn't know gucci made first suits that's crazy i
mean hey you know those are expensive though yeah you know
and it's got it's got my sweat all over it as well oh my god
yeah he's gonna be off that scent it's got that flavor check
out ebay after this match he's gonna be auctioning medical
bills after that bro you saw me playing with my gamer sweat
you saw me play oops sorry I got a call guys I'm getting his
cash out right now he's getting his cash out from V yeah
yeah yeah whoa whoa whoa I ain't checking my paper sorry
that's my money is transferred oh no they calling me shit
but hey you know I mean you saw you guys saw me playing with
my food and you know make it rigging the odds a bit you know
because i was i was smashing her at the start yeah you did
everyone's like oh my god axel's gonna win and then that's
gonna like all right cinema time time okay that's when i
that's when i went nah i'd win guys his post also looks like
an absolute cinema moment look at that guys look at that
hell look hell yeah but yeah congratulations to The
tournament organizer is the winner!
Not rigged!
Wrestling is not scripted, guys.
I'm just saying, hey!
Hey, I'm just saying, Doki.
It's a win-win situation, right?
I know, yeah, yeah.
And the viewers, they were entertained.
Were they not?
Because we split the cash, right?
We made it look so real, right?
Hell no!
Take your fucking dub and get it.
Take your fucking dub.
Hell no.
Take your dub and go home, bro.
all right g g's axe it's too bad i can't pummel you again oh
well maybe maybe next time maybe next year 2025 wrestle
tuber oh next year we're doing the game dude i'm gonna be
i'm gonna be running back we'll run it back of course of
course why else would there be 2024 i want to rematch next
time drive will last longer than one round make it a series
i'm gonna make my character bulkier this time
but yeah is there any more it's about that mentality yeah
yeah it is there any more opponents that we can like uh well
i think i think we're going to an intermission yeah One more
final intermission for one last caster rotation.
We have two games left, everybody.
So we're going to rotate our casters to Philly and Snuffy
for the last two games.
So we're going to go to the intermission now.
Let's thank Octavia and Gerard for the casting, everybody.
Yeah, thank you.
Thank you.
Bowing, bowing, bowing.
Thank you for having us here.
And really sorry about the dumb comments that we've been
making.
It's just our first time.
Really sorry about that.
I just want to fucking wrestle.
That's it Own the casting you think I know what I'm talking
about.
We called the fucking no London bridge is falling down and
the So we're going intermission now right we're going into
the break During a break make sure to check the V bet apps
and make sure to bet on the underdog Nice to see you guys
all.
All right.
Bye.
I got to kick you guys off the main stage to leave all right
intermission now
hello everybody we're this is backstage doki here getting
ready for the final the final two matches i am not on screen
because this is backstage stage dokey not caster dokey right
now um we have two final matches um casted by phillian and
snuffy let me uh call them in real quick guys gotta put them
on the table real quick chat let's get we gotta find them
where could they be where could they be guys where did they
go
there's one of them she's here all right don't worry i
pushed her in here she doesn't have her mic set up yet guys
we didn't put the headphones in yet guys so give us a sec
don't worry we have our second caster here our second caster
and there she is there she is we have our final two matches
bulk vulgan versus do king and betta versus octavio let's
get them in the room put the mics on them real fast
hello welcome are you guys ready to cast yeah you guys are
on the main screen now oh they got the budget for me i may
be 240p but at least i'm animated what the hell i've been
flattened and condensed why am i so fuzzy bro we look we
look like an episode of amazing world of god bro we're
redacted
all right well you know i'm done beating children it's time
to cast them so let's definitely get down to this junk it
says backstage do you guys remember who what are the two
last matches me yeah i mean you're casting do you guys know
of course yes let me just go check my dm look at the casters
please look at the broadcast chat casters i'm afraid oh
broadcast chat yeah you i watched that match that was really
epic you were i thought you were i didn't think you were
gonna make it i didn't think you were gonna make it i'll be
honest with you am i interviewing you yeah you're gonna
interview me and sarah guys you're the cat guys why are you
asking me questions you're the casters i'm backstage dokey
wait i don't i don't see any i don't see i don't see I don't
see who's up next.
I don't see who's up next.
What do you mean?
I typed in it wrong.
Well, that's really crazy because apparently I can't read.
Oh.
I see.
Okay.
And I just got word from the caster's desk.
I put my hand in my ear to look really cool while I'm doing
it.
But right now I'm a V-Tuber, so you can't see that.
So our next match, I'm getting word, is going to be no one
other than Backstage Doki coming out to the forefront.
She's back.
And her opponent is not other than Miss Sarah Saraw however
you say it she's here to fight Saraw Wait, how did it Sarah
Saraw I'm getting blamed in the comments right now.
Oh my god Let me put you guys into the castors aren't here
The castors are walking here guys Oh gosh, you guys are so
big Sorry
there we go the casters are here now but sarah's not give us
a sec we're waiting for her sorry sorry i'm just here for
some reason still don't worry there she is oh i arrived oh
beautiful beautiful very nice i like the snake oh what will
there if i win it will come out at the end yeah No, you're
not allowed to bring summons into the arena, right?
Yeah, that's not fair.
If you can bring a snake, I can bring a Jaguar.
But you are the Jaguar.
Are you not Mr. King?
I can have two.
Oh, it's not fair.
We're turning this whole match into a jungle at this point.
I mean, we are.
I mean, like, 99% of the people here are, I mean, 100% of us
are animals.
No, don't tell me is that.
I'm not amongst you.
What do you mean you literally have cat ears?
Bro, that's not...
No, these are fake.
They're actually canonically fake.
They're canonically fake.
I can take them off.
Okay, when she was like...
When I was like, hey, which wrestler do you want to
represent in you?
She was like, my chat wants the furry run, so I'm going to
pick that one.
Oh, my God.
You don't believe me.
I'm a caster, okay?
I'm going to cast against you biestly.
You're not supposed to be biased.
Yeah, I'm going to do it, okay?
It's my first time I can do whatever I want No, she's like
good cop, bad cop I have to let this happen It's like okay,
you're the good cop I'm the cop on the streets and drugs and
steals them Okay, don't let me mess with me What's the good
cop?
What are you gonna say to us?
Oh, um, everybody do your best Right?
I want a boy Well Yeah That's my way Yeah, just doing our
best You got this, I believe doing great all right you're
fucking going Sarah you're going down i came back from a
fighting game championship i know my fighting moves now so
you're going down oh my god you know i've i've heard i've
heard a lot about your uh incredible fighting style dorky
yeah uh i'm gonna put dorky in the turkey i didn't come up
with anything that i use my a material i use my a material
What are these insults?
Oh man, I...
Am I out of my A material?
In the semis?
Who let this child in?
I mean, she does some weird stuff, I don't know.
Why is she...
Who let the snake in?
It's true.
I was like, who let her have that?
Who let the snake in too?
We have two very fierce...
opponents going after each other well what the are you also
gonna land on doking and pummel her sarah um oh i hope so
like you know if i could i i have a track record of um one
successful landing so far so if i can make it to two i might
be the safest fictional airline in this entire competition
let's go let's go better than mine already give it up chat
for two amazing contestants let's go i'm really curious if
we're gonna get fired snuffy how do you think we're gonna do
tonight uh okay i'm literally right behind you i'm giving
you the ropes guys why are we kissing why are you like
whispering what do you mean all right here we go this is the
match the following is scheduled for one fall representing
Sarah none other than the biggest the meanest the greenest
bulk bogus holy freak this guy's insane where'd you find
this dude an absolute legend Is there supposed to be like an
intro music?
Should we make it up?
I think there probably is intro music.
Okay, now we can hear it.
There she is.
Oh, wait.
Logan!
She's beautiful.
Bro, it looks like she caught out of a sarcophagus in Egypt.
I mean, this is eccentric, to say the least.
It looks like she might corrode you.
She's radioactive.
She kind of looks like she's wearing Peter Griffin's outfit.
gonna lie she comes here ready for combat hey yo these
chiseled features don't lie no she looks like a superhero
look at oh she's unleashing the beast oh my she call her a
teenage mutant ninja turtle because this radioactive person
is transforming the beast my god she's striking more poses
than an effing naruto hitting the effing fireball jutsu i
don't what she's doing we definitely got to pay our camera
guy a little bit more money all right let's go bulk bogan
sir ra is already putting on a show ladies and gentlemen
business casual but yet so fierce and wild will we see her
perform in the ring today will we see you taking a gun out
it's all part of that wild nature Ooh, here comes the
entrance.
A little saucy with it.
It's going to make a lean, a little bit of a zesty approach,
but oh, okay.
I think the cross is holding the ropes like we're making
sweet love to it.
And she's in.
I mean, this person's an actual fiend.
I'm not going to lie.
I'm a bit worried for Dokey right now.
This person seems a little bit unhinged, to say the least.
Yeah, this person is a caged animal ready to be unleashed at
any given moment.
uh 911 responders in the back with tasers and uh equipment
i'm getting unnamed equipment just in case it gets too feral
she's been known to go absolutely hog wild joki might not
make it today speaking about quip i think she's looking
pretty good in that department let's see how she does i
don't know man this person's like peak darwin evolution
right now sarah is looking insane I think she was bred
solely just for her muscle compatibility.
Look how built she is.
Look at this pure primal nature.
She's currently seeking and sensing her prey.
That's true, Blake.
Introducing her opponent.
Everybody knows the word.
Yoki!
Holy freak, this man's got the every vocal capacity of an
effing whale.
That's insane.
And here's our next challenge of the night.
All right, it's such a pleasure to cast her match.
We just witnessed an amazing fight by the king.
And now we're about to watch if she will bring it back
another time.
But she's versus an opponent who is just as fierce and feral
as Do King himself.
This is going to be quite intense.
I do have a question for you, Snuffy.
Do you think she's going to take off the mask?
I thought she might have just done it.
A rare mask reveal.
There's only three of them sold on eBay right now.
That's true.
Things were never the same after the dream mask reveal.
So we're going to see if she keeps us on or not.
But she is making her way down to the arena right now.
Slamming her head on the metal stairs.
Do you think you're allowed to use that in combat here or
not?
I want to see some steel stair gameplay.
There are no rules in wrestling.
This is just pure wild animalistic fighting.
Yeah, you can say that again.
I mean, it's yapping Jaguar versus Serp matchup.
I mean, Slytherin or Hufflepuff, who's going to win this
one?
Wait, Gryffindor?
I don't know what I'm saying.
Anyway, I don't know, bro.
I didn't watch the book, okay?
So we're going to see how she can do here tonight.
Wait, can we talk to chat?
Can we read our commentators with the fans of saying live?
I'm kind of curious.
Am I breaking the immersion?
Let's find out.
I'm getting word.
There's a lot of people in the crowd whispering my ears
simultaneously at all a very condensed volume.
Watch the book, they say.
Oh, that's a weird quote.
Oh, my God.
She goes straight up in the suplex.
I mean, the 49ers are about to draft this chick.
And she's going and grabbing a dokey bird and throwing her
straight into the railing.
Oh, my God.
What was that move?
She hit the butt slam with that anime.
She did the peach sidebeat.
Oh, my God.
Dokey is not starting her match very strongly.
She has spent more time on the floor than her feet on the
ground.
I mean, she might be a wobble fit.
We'll have to see if she's a late bloomer in this situation.
Oh my god.
Oh, she's just getting her whole body.
Circus delayed over here.
The spider monkey maneuver didn't work out that well for
Sarah.
Now Doki Bird with the reversal.
She might have the upper hand.
Just kidding.
She's getting Joker live in Porte.
This is that kind of animalistic nature I told you about.
Once she's unleashed, there is no going back.
We will have to, oh my god, Doki.
I mean, we might lose the fatality in the first few seconds.
I never thought I'd see it live.
She's going through the throat.
Rather than take her ability to win this fight, she's
ruining her ability to win an apex game.
Doki is on the run.
She is currently hiding and screaming, begging for life
right now.
She is too afraid to sit back in the ring.
She's on the eagle kick.
The eagle kick of the seventh condor.
Oh my God.
I never.
Jesus Christ.
She goes for the back of the head slam.
I, uh, what just happened?
Doki.
Doki just rage quit the game.
I repeat.
Doki.
Is this stream paused?
I think this stream paused, Doki.
But we're live on a five second delay.
I'm sure they're actually killing each other right now.
They are.
Doki had to take this off camera.
This can no longer be broadcasted onto live TV.
We had to go to the backstage cameras right now.
Doki is currently grabbing her by the hair.
Oh, she's getting, oh, my God.
This is truly any man's game.
All the rules are broken.
They're getting back in the ring.
Back into the stadium.
I mean, there's high ground versus low ground.
We saw all this worked out in the Star Wars, but Doki Bird
also did see that.
So she is coming back into the arena now.
We are out of five minutes now on the ground.
around with a 360 kick spin off the rails.
That's probably what's happening.
Oh my god, that's exactly what happened.
And Sarah said Doki right over.
Doki is kicking her in the jaw.
Now she's grabbing her by the toes?
What?
Yeah, she's grabbing the toes and everything.
We're live on television again.
We're live on television.
We're so back in real time.
It looks like she's hitting it with a muffler 3000, and
Sarah is literally not feeling it this time, but she keeps
grabbing her feet.
I'm starting to think there's a little bit, again, Oh my
god.
This might be motivated by some odd Oh my god Four kicks.
Imagine how many Tessicles would have been lost just now.
Has to be in pieces Already.
Oh She just grabbed her by the left cheek And then she just
snapped her own neck Snapped her own neck That was insane.
And Sarah said Not today bitch.
Oh my Incredible kick with the flim spray I mean this is
getting violent.
I mean This is just Oh, it's all over.
Wait, she's going with the triangle.
She's got her.
This could be it.
It's the first one.
Come on, Doki.
It's just Doki in the match.
There's no way Doki goes down without a fight.
She's near the back of that.
It's free.
She's got that Jaguar prowl.
Oh, my God.
That was like Kiso landing on Jinxi.
I mean, I think she might be dead.
Two.
Oh, my God.
Sarah's not done yet.
She's about to show us the true nature.
Her anaconda don't want nothing unless Doki's got buns, one.
uh okay i don't think it was a very effective maneuver but
it did look swagtastic i'm not gonna lie maybe we can count
on the snake to save sarah after all this isn't looking good
oh my god god curb stopper doggy for the content she just
let her get back up no doggy's just toying with her oh my
god she's the king oh my god she's tossing around like a
five-year-old playing with a barbie doll she's just flinging
her around.
Jesus Christ and the legendary triple suplex.
This might be it, ladies and gentlemen.
I mean, we're getting angles for sure.
Uh, at 2000.
Oh, Sarah can still fight.
Unbelievable after being tossed around like a Gmod rag doll.
We're moving straight out of leg pin land straight into face
knee city.
I don't think Sarah's got much left in the tank at this
point, but don't keep her misses a knee.
The clutch sniff of 5,000.
okay oh my god this is insane this is insane and now sarah's
turned to gloat this has just become an illusion of fighting
they are just i think they're all just pure adrenaline at
this point whoa out of nowhere he could not fight back taps
out just like that here's your winner Why tap out?
Representing Sarah Balls!
Bogan!
And they have a snake!
Oh my god, they have a snake!
She's got the fucking snake!
Oh my god!
We get this snake!
No, you can't break the snake on here!
Who said you can break the snake in here?
Someone get the trick.
This cannot be legal.
We need the staff on the stage now.
Staff...
be making a guest appearance that's crazy but dude i did not
expect uh dokey bird to tap out in the final moments that
was a really unexpected ending i mean any man's game they
were practically both out of stamina it just became just
teeth and claw at that point i know i know you know sarah
might have hit it with the snake venom attack and it took
down her stamina over the course of the fight yeah she got
that medusa glare and put dokey down yeah i don't get the
flag for uh casting a game where dokey got eliminated but
hey we're back with her right now That was a fight.
Oh, my God.
Tell us about it.
Axel, like, introduced me to this app called Vibets.
And, you know, I got a little bit addicted there.
So I might have lost a fight, but end up a millionaire.
So that's fine with me.
And that's it.
That's really it.
It could have, I won't say it was rigged, but, like, I got a
hefty amount.
amount of cash coming in soon.
Sarah, your response to this?
All I gotta say is, you know, it's like they say in
wrestling.
Sooner or later, everyone taps.
And today it was Docky.
So sorry.
Got Doki and the Choki and it happened.
Oh yeah.
Not Rids.
Oh god.
I can't believe it actually happened.
It's so cute.
the joke wait it actually happened yeah the ending the
finishing move right yeah well sorry can you tell us how you
kept yeah oh yeah what's your snake name yeah my snake name
is jinn but i mean like okay so like the the reason that my
wrestle looks the way it is is because we're like a package
deal but since there's two of us we would have get we would
have got dq'd if we went in together so we did a fusion
dance and the abomination that is bulk gorgon is a mixture
of me and my snake um but then what is left over is the
snake in the bag i don't know a snake barista could be so
buff you guys are like the wonder twins that's what they do
that's what they do call us in the streets yes two people
i'm one this is not you have a tomato in you don't you have
a tomato in you don't you have a I mean, it's a cosmetic.
It's not like I have a second person.
It's like me putting on a fucking hat, which I am wearing
one, too.
So it's like wearing two hats.
I feel like it's like you and your eyebrows.
Like, imagine if you didn't have your eyebrows.
Would you be half the dokey you are?
I feel like you would be missing a whole part of yourself.
I just think, you know what?
You know, okay, all right, fine.
You know, the better, the better wrestler won.
I'll admit, the better rest are what.
You were an incredible opponent, Doki.
Like, I'm going to take this whole thing out just to prove
that you were one of the best.
Yeah, okay, you got to win the finals then.
If you beat me and you win, that means I'm the winner, too,
because I lost to the winner.
So, like, technically I'm also coming with me on this.
I'm taking you along for the ride.
It's okay.
Yeah, yeah.
I know.
Oh, I'm...
All right.
Jack, Doki Bird Watchers, where is it?
the bird watchers the ruffians what killing off this amazing
fight we just witnessed let's go you don't know my fans
names on my own channel
thank you to our viewers like you
which match is next who's who's who's up to the chopping
block now well i sure am gonna know because I do know.
A clown!
Oh.
I sure wish I knew what I was doing.
A clown?
And then...
Hello?
Yeah, that's me.
That's me.
I'm a clown.
Hi!
Well, you better be funny.
Yes, you are.
Oh, I'm not.
Wait, wait.
I need to do introduction.
I need to be a professional, but I don't know who the names
are.
Oh, my God.
All right.
Okay, okay.
I got it.
I got this.
So I actually knew the entire time.
I was just big trolling.
Yeah, yeah, take your time.
Okay, so first off, we are going to introduce.
Okay, I just saw four different names, but one of them is
definitely Octavio.
So what's up, Octavio?
Hello.
Bad tally.
Oh, hi, over y'all.
Sick, nasty.
Okay, wait, so which one's which?
I'm so sorry.
I'm sorry.
Yeah, you got it.
You got it.
Why don't you guess, guess, like, pick, pick.
Okay, Octavio is a clown or is he boom man?
Let's see.
You have to pick.
I'm going to guess.
Octavio sounds really effing quirked up.
I'm going to say he's the clown.
Yikes.
On live TV.
Mr. Clown.
Is your name Charlie by any chance?
Yeah.
Let's go.
Let's go, dude.
Okay.
Hey, guys.
Charlie here.
These days.
Well, Mr. Charlie, how does it feel to fight your Kohai.
Oh, man, it feels good.
It feels good.
It feels good to just, I'm going, I'm just gotta wipe the
floor with this guy.
He's gotta be going Octavio.
I'm like Octavio.
Oh, no.
Stop it.
Sexy Clown Man for fucking enemy in the head.
You're tied.
Beddle?
I have to say something.
First off, it's Charlie.
I think you're cool.
I think you're handsome.
I think you're admirable.
I think you're inspirational.
Uh-huh.
Thanks.
Thank you.
i want to do some actual violence what the frick is this
about yeah yeah like what is this go kiss at this what the
hell i did a name pun i worked like five i practiced that
for like five minutes before i got here yeah well i hope you
probably just as much you can do those in seconds like but
tell well you but tell not tell anybody you're gonna die
today what the hell what is this This is biased commentary.
What on earth?
You're supposed to remain neutral.
No, no.
See, it's good cop, bad cop.
Yeah.
Yeah, Philly already dunked on Octavia.
It's my turn now.
Philly called me Charlie.
Yeah, we're tagged even.
Wait, which one am I talking to?
Oh my God.
Are you kidding me?
Do your research.
What is this?
I'm just kidding.
Okay.
Guys, tell me right now.
what is your signature move what what what secret technique
are you planning on using this match i'm gonna show beddle
my blue balls all right that's not on my signature move uh
is the open hand slap oh dang a pimp i respect that oh my
gosh okay okay i mean we'll see what wins balls are slapping
you're my same client i can't i can't disrespect you right
now slap this ball i'm gonna destroy i'm gonna defile your
body in the ring what okay well jesus i'm sensing a lot of
tension in this match i think we should go to the match i'm
gonna go a strong rivalry okay gav is brittle yeah i'm
sensing some energy here might be a little romantic i'm not
gonna lie well i can't wait to see how this fight unfolds
slay all right let's well just manfic
Okay.
What on earth?
What are those characters, bro?
They both are making insane expressions upon seeing one
another.
Octavio.
In two different directions.
The other one.
The following contest is our final match for night one.
Introducing first Octavio.
That is a freaking wizard.
I know.
This dude definitely casts fireballs on the weekend.
It looks like he's about a...
He kind of looks like a jellyfish.
Judgment.
What beautiful eyeliner.
I just rizzed me up.
I'm going to need the name of his makeup artist.
He's got a doll.
I know.
I thought we would stop at body pillows, but apparently not.
That might be his sister, dude.
Yeah, it might be.
I bet it stands up on its own.
We'd have to find out.
So let's see what this man's got going on.
I mean, he's like a walking jellyfish.
He's kind of intense.
Oh my god, I can't look at this guy.
I think he might have meant to go to the raid next door.
I'm not going to lie to you.
I don't know if he knows this is wrestling.
This man looks like he paid 90 bucks for a six pack of
water.
I mean, this dude's serious business right now.
I mean, does he know where the camera is?
I don't think this guy's looked away a single time.
I think we would all be better off if he would buy less
avocado toast.
Dang, you just roast an entire state.
that's crazy all right he's rolling up let's see they don't
call him octavio for nothing kind of sounds like an emperor
name what is his legacy oh my god yo i think they might be
like a rock star maybe that's what the vibe i'm getting off
he's he's a rock artist i think he's just an arsonist i'm
not gonna lie he's casting fire someone in chat wrote No,
no, no, no.
It's Hatsumi Miku.
True.
And his opponent, noticed Charlie in some circles, has
defeated his brother to be here.
It's battle!
That's the one who wins.
There's so many little frogs on the stage.
I know, he's already into the arena.
This man works fast as frick.
I think he might be all about business.
He might be a clown.
He might be joking and funny and humorous, but he's all
about business here.
He wasn't the type of guy to tip a razor blade to his shoe.
I don't trust him for a moment.
I mean, this guy under that hat.
That's what I'm afraid of.
Wait, that was the shortest intro in history.
This dude's here for winning money and leaving.
I think that means he's ready to kill.
Yeah.
All right, well, battle versus Octavia.
Let's see how this one rolls out.
Why did he swap to an effing D-Word dress?
will we see kissing let's find out oh my god we're about to
see tony off pro skater kick flip riding him like a freaking
skateboard okay way to open up the match oh and he does it
again i mean this dude's doing more flips than me right now
oh oh my god oh my god oh my god okay octavia he just did a
bay blade no wait octavia's already getting he's gone Oh,
Beto got tossed.
These guys are strong.
Can you get their grandpa back in the retirement home?
I don't think he's meant to be here.
Oh, and just like that.
Oh, my God.
He's back up.
Oh, a triple back flip.
I hope Grandpa didn't bring his dentures.
Beto is here to fight.
Oh, my God.
He's flying around the match like a trapeze.
Is that already?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, he's got more than this.
He's ready to show the world what he told us he was going to
do.
do i think octavia's already running for his life he might
get knocked off the back rope right now my man missed his
takedown maneuver and got head pinched into the what he's
blinded by the leds oh my god oh my god the sheer amount of
light reflection that octavia's outfit is causing right now
i know he's blind to smell like the lights either we can
definitely get him a copyright
The epic head slam the whip last year is probably a
equivalent of a 60-mile-an-hour car crash.
We're not heard this going on.
That was the sickest move I have ever seen in all wrestling
history.
That was the coolest thing I have ever witnessed.
Usually when guys do the helicopters by themselves, I mean,
this one's crazy.
I think we should hire clouds to fight more often because
that is just getting sick.
I mean, I think I'm watching a Yowie fold in real time.
I'm not gonna lie.
This is the Johnny Appleseed.
Whoa!
He's like a folding chair!
Holy shit!
He's not.
Okay.
Betel is taking Octavio in literally any position he can get
him in.
This is insane.
Oh my god!
How many back flips does he need before his back flipped
enough?
I think he's trying to impress you, Phil.
Is it true?
Oh my god!
I cannot comment on this right now!
I'm literally making love on the stage!
That's half of the bag filled and now his luts are popped!
Oh my god!
Octavio's got him!
He's in with the epic sword!
What is he doing?
He's showing the whole world his senpai.
It's just getting folded like a banana.
Insane.
Octavio!
Oh my god!
damage to himself okay oh my god they're just jumping off of
each other at this point they're playing my leap frog in oh
right against the oh my god this is getting dirty yeah this
is getting absolutely she said not to worry about neither of
them look like they want to get back into the ring oh my god
combo this is it oh wait snuff you don't forget you cannot
pin outside of the arena so that means that currently battle
is safer being eliminated unless he's stunned until 10
seconds runs out.
It's almost there.
We've got seven seconds.
That doesn't get back in right now.
He's taunting.
But he is taunting.
He nearly timed out and he is taunting.
I'm not even sure if his head is screwed on straight
anymore.
I don't think it ever was.
I mean, this dude's tenacious.
He's an actual maniac.
I would not want to fight this guy.
Oh, my God.
You hit him with the industrial head slicer.
I've seen that on a live place before.
And now, I think...
I don't know.
Oh my god.
Grandpa is down.
He's playing dirty.
Grandpa got his arm snapped.
I hope he can cast a healing spell.
Oh, but that won't save him.
Oh, he's got him.
He's got him.
There's no way.
It's over.
That'll packed up Octavio in the car.
Here is your winner, Charlie Ben.
Okay, that was an insane fight.
I witnessed more yoga moves there than I have in the
entirety of my career in yoga.
I mean, that was a simply acrobatic fight.
I saw more skin and body angles than I did in the entire
just chatting section of Twitch.
That was insane.
I think that was a true test of wrestling supremacy right
there.
That was beautiful.
That was a true art form.
It was.
You couldn't have said it.
any better god damn oh was there any doubt a little bit was
there any doubt in i charlie gavis betel oh that was good
that was good yo i liked i like how he danced around the
battlefield yeah we showed i'll touch each other's skin it's
the dude from konosuba that's crazy i think we were off the
ground more than we were on it in that fight yeah yeah you
were like rabbits pounding each other on each other i have
never seen so much um
inspiration athleticism skill yes yes passion for the fight
yeah that was a good whole movie i'm not gonna lie i respect
it yeah we're amateurs though
all right battle battle congratulations on the win or is
there ever any doubt in your mind congrats no no i i don't
doubt myself i am i am a man of pure and unbridled
confidence i mean it's just the way things go do you know
what it takes to win this entire tournament yeah that was an
insane showcasing of skill i think i think you have
potential oh no he doesn't i'm gonna beat him I've already
won.
I've already won.
Anyone can face me.
It's a considerate done.
All right, viewers, you've heard it here.
He's already won.
So let's take it back to backstage Doki coming front stage
for our last remaining things to say for today.
Thanks, Doki.
Don't fire me.
She would, all right, Philly would read anything in the
Discord chat, which I figured out.
I literally wrote Charlie versus Octavio and she actually
read I was like are those these guys are these guys just
like are they coming on to help I was too afraid to say
their names I knew him that his name was but tell but then
he said like three of their names so I was like are you I'll
put these is this like a 40 for the key cast confusion bro
you wrote like you wrote you wrote like five different
versus octavio charlie versus octavio bettle bettle versus
octavio i didn't know what was going on uh huge thank you to
fillian and stuffy for casting the last two matches if you
enjoy the casting they will be casting more matches tomorrow
we lost track of time and matches um so because of that i
forgot to put them in earlier but do not worry they're gonna
be casting more much more balanced but yes give a huge shout
out and thank you to our casters fillian and snuffy woohoo
thank you for having me yeah yeah we'll see you guys
tomorrow and i'm gonna do an outro for the viewers and also
give a final note on who are the what are the matches for
tomorrow I'll see you guys later, guys.
Adios, chat.
All right, peace out.
Let's go.
All right, I just left the call because I don't know how
long they're going to be there.
Let's bring them in and bring me back into this.
Bring me back into this.
Like I said, huge thank you to all the casters, Gerard,
Octavio, Mint, Philly, have Taka filling in for Sayu to do
the announcement very last minute literally like five to ten
minutes before our stream was about to start uh Taka filled
in um and uh we were trying he tried very hard to like try
to get the feeling of the announcements so a huge shout out
to Taka another big shout out to my sound guy for doing all
the balancing live i'm sorry if the balancing needs the
voice the the sound balancing might need a little bit more
work I'm not sure yet, because I don't know.
I can't rewatch the bot to see if anything needs balancing.
But yes, a huge shout out to all the cast, everybody that
participated for like five hours.
We've been going at it for five hours for day one.
Now, some of you guys are wondering what will be on day two.
Day two.
We do have some matches that weren't able to be played, so
we're going to be playing some of those matches.
me get out my handy text tool real quick guys all right so
from here Emma Emma made it out from here so let me put Emma
here we're doing this live everybody Emma will be here they
may oh my gosh white text is not it here we go sorry this is
um a little scuffed here from Emma made it to the finals for
day two we also have for tomorrow we will have Fuyo versus
Snuffy and Nana who versus whoever wins that second bracket
so let me copy and paste real quick put that here as Nana
has defeated Gerard we'll fix it in post It's a live
experience.
You know this is not pre-recorded.
So from here, this will be bracket one.
These are the matches that we are going to have.
We're going to have Boyo versus Snuffy tomorrow.
And then we'll have Nana versus whoever wins that matchup.
And then Emma right here.
The second bracket.
Okay, where's my other image?
Guys, this is my first time organizing this, guys.
I haven't never organized a wrestling event before.
on Doki Bird.
So, please be nice.
So, second matchup will be Anon versus whoever wins the Luto
versus Siyu matchup.
So, we have figuring that out.
Anon will be here.
We're going to figure out who is going to win in the Luto
versus Siyu.
And then, we have Philean in the finals.
Because she beat up a child and then another child too so
billion will be in the finals and then finally in bracket
three bracket three we will have we will have sarah making
it to the finals Sarah making it to the finals And Beto
versus Sarah Well actually no, sorry JK, I forgot If you
think it's going to be Beto versus Sarah It'll actually be
We will be mixing up the matchups And we'll spin a wheel on
who's going to fight who For the final matches So those who
made it all the way to The finals here with Sarah and Beto
We're going to be mixing it up again So they're not going to
be fighting each other We're going to be mixing up the
matchups for the final finals.
And that will be day two.
And finally, the show matches for our show matches.
We will have Shy Lily, Lucy, Meriwether, and Buff Puff for a
2v2 tornado tag team as our show match for tomorrow.
Not dogs.
I don't know.
What do I describe the other?
What would they be called, guys?
Tomorrow, our show match will be a tag team.
Dogs versus not dogs.
I don't know what the group would...
What would you call the group of Shilily and Lucy?
But yes, like I said, you'd shout out to everybody for being
here.
And Juna was also a huge shout out for Juna for being the
interviewer and stayed out throughout the whole day.
I think she passed out right after a huge shout out to Juna
for being here and doing the interview process with
everybody.
And I'm very excited for day two.
I hope you guys have enjoyed the matches so far.
And I know it's a little bit scuffed.
I am a one-man team.
bit scuffed but i hope you guys still had lots of fun um um
as you know there is this wrestling belt has been revealed
this will be our official wrestling belt that will be sent
to the winners of both the show matches and the tournament
and i'm super excited to see who is going to win this belt
uh thank you everybody um we i hope you will enjoy day one
it has been a Long day, five hours, but it's honestly been
amazing.
It's been an amazing experience, and I hope my staff team
enjoyed themselves a lot.
Casting and announcing and just having a great time with
everybody.
And I hope you fans enjoyed it too.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture checked, get up
and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stayed up for me, head to bed, because you
deserve it.
everyone!
Day two!
Bye bye guys!
Bye!